[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux d'avoir
trouvé cet après midi sur public sénat
pour le temps fort du mercredi au sénat
les questions au gouvernement à 15
heures les sénateurs vont interroger les
ministres sur les sujets du moment et on
va vous faire vivre cet après midi avec
toute notre équipe est d'abord notre
commentateur en tribune de presse de
l'hémicycle du sénat quand un calme est
apparent bonjour programme cet après
midi il va être beaucoup question
d'écologie aujourd'hui on attend deux
questions sur l'ultimatum lancé par le
conseil d'état la semaine dernière dans
la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique
on va revenir aussi sur l'abandon
annoncé hier par le gouvernement de la
révision constitutionnelle sur le climat
merci quentin nous serons également avec
notre interview heures en salle des
conférences du sénat steve jourdain vous
allé recueillir les réactions des
sénateurs des ministres qui auraient
vous à votre micro
bonjour alex bonjour à tous le
gouvernement tape très fort actuellement
sur le sénat et l'accusent d'avoir en
quelque sorte sa beauté le référendum
sur le climat promis par emmanuel macron
on verra ce qu'en pense notamment le
sénateur dallaire philippe bas dans un
instant et dans ce trio du mercredi il
ya également jean m'assieds le streamer
politique qui va commenter cette séance
de questions d'actualité sur la
plateforme twitch avec toute sa
communauté dans son émission sénat
stream salut jean comment ça va
on va retrouver jean tout à l'heure à
14h30
nous évoquerons la présidentielle et
cette question comment désigner le
candidat de la droite à la
présidentielle faut-il organiser à
organiser une primaire de la droite et
du centre ou alors est bien se ranger
derrière xavier bertrand le candidat le
mieux placé dans les sondages pour
éviter un duel emmanuel macron marine le
pen au second tour ce sera le vrai notre
face à face entre d'un côté olivier
paccaud sénateur de l'oise
rattaché au groupe l'est républicain
soutien de xavier bertrand et de l'autre
philippe mouillé sénateurs l ère des
deux sèvres est proche de valérie
pécresse
mais d'abord on va s'intéresser à
l'agenda des réformes d'emmanuel macron
et notamment à la réforme des retraites
aura t lieu avant la fin du quinquennat
pour en parler sur ce plateau âge
accueille philippe dallier sénateur les
républicains de seine-saint-denis
bonjour jacquin également monique lubin
sénatrice socialiste des landes
bonjour et puis nous serons à distance
avec françois-xavier olivo directeur
associé d'initiative & finance et vous
avez publié et bien le livre intitulé la
crise de l'abondance aux édition de
l'observatoire bonjour bonjour également
en visio erwan tison économiste et
directeur des études de l'institut
sapiens bonjour erwan saison je précise
également que vous avez publié cette
semaine une tribune dans le journal les
échos une tribune intitulée retraite
pour une dose de capitalisation
alors avant de débattre de cette réforme
des retraites on va revenir sur le
sommet social organisé hier à l'élysée
emmanuel macron a été à l'écouté des
syndicats et du patronat sans dévoiler
ses intentions sur la réforme des
retraites
les explications de mathias arese
presque quatre heures de réunion ce
mardi matin à l'élysée n'auront pas
suffi à mettre tout le monde d'accord
concernant le projet de réforme des
retraites souhaitée par emmanuel macron
tg fait part d'un sondage qui est sorti
ce week end
qui dit qu' un français sur dix
soutiennent sa réforme
julie bas comme vous êtes fort en maths
déduisez qui en a neuf sur dix qui sont
pas d'accord
pour les organisations syndicales il
faut de toute urgence mettre le pied sur
le frein et recentrer les efforts sur la
relance économique de prendre des
décisions aujourd'hui c'est plus que
prématurée ça serait même hors de propos
dans la période que nous sommes en train
de vivre je crois que je crois même que
avoir dit qu'il y avait un risque social
et démocratique
côté patronat on émet également des
réserves sur le calendrier
tout en rappelant son soutien au recul
de l'âge de départ
non mais il a juste rappelé ce qui est
une évidence et que tous les autres pays
ont fait ce type de réformes et que pour
financer le modèle social français et
européens il faut plus de quantité de
travail une proposition qui hérisse les
poils des représentants des travailleurs
qui n'entendent pas repartir sur les
mêmes bases et donc là dessus on est en
désaccord on l'était en laye et on le
sera si ça revient
de cette manière là il ne faudra pas
compter sur nous le chef de l'état qui
dit rentrée dorénavant dans une période
de réflexion devrait s'exprimer sur la
question d'ici le 14 juillet emmanuel
macron qui réfléchit donc à remettre sur
la table cette réforme des retraites
avant la fin du quinquennat
philippe dallier ce que ce serait une
bonne idée de faire cette réforme avant
la présidentielle
cette réforme d'abord quelles réformes
sur des parties de parler sur le fond
oui voilà mais la question est quand
même importante
on est parti d'une volonté de d'une
réforme systémique qui a point qui
remettrait tout le monde sur le même
plan d'égalité avec une complexité
incroyable d'ailleurs à tel point que
personne n'y comprenait rien ce qui a
été très anxiogène pour les français là
on serait sûr quoi sur une option d'une
réforme paramétrique avec une mesure
d'âge uniquement des je ne sais pas
première première question et bruit à la
question du calendrier
je pense que on n'est pas sorti de la
crise de la pandémie c'est pas certain
de la crise économique
ça va durer encore un certain temps et
nous sommes surtout à quelques mois de
la campagne présidentielle je pense que
pour une réforme aussi importante il
faut que la présidentielle soit
l'occasion de poser le débat que les
différents candidats affichent leurs
options et il sera bien temps été
prochain lorsque le président a une
nouvelle majorité ont été élus de mettre
en oeuvre
la réforme qui aura qui aura fait partie
du programme d'un candidat
voilà le faire maintenant le fer à
l'automne dans l'est dans la situation
actuelle du pays
ça ça me semble être prendre un risque
politique pour le pays pas seulement
pour le président de la république et sa
majorité trop important sur le
calendrier de cette réforme des
retraites quelle que soit la forme on va
en parler de la forme que pourrait
prendre cette réforme monique lubin
ce serait une folie pour reprendre les
mots du patron de la cfdt laurent berger
de la faire avant à la fin du
quinquennat
oui je pense en effet que ce serait ce
serait une folie parce que nous sommes
encore en pleine crise pandémique est
d'ailleurs les informations que j'ai pu
entendre il ya seulement quelques
minutes nous démontre que nous n'en
sommes pas sortis et que peut-être les
français auront à faire de nouveau à de
nouvelles restrictions peut être minime
mais de liberté
donc nous sommes dans une phase où les
français sont quand même anxieux
certains ont perdu leur emploi
certains auront du mal à retrouver ça
n'est vraiment pas le moment d'aller
aujourd'hui leur parler d'une réforme
qui va les impacts et mais ils ne savent
pas comment
et puis je pense que ça serait une
tromperie démocratique parce que le
président de la république n'avait pas
mis cela dans son programme en 2017 et
il reste à peine quelques mois nous
savons que la mandature va se terminer
fin février
est-ce qu'il est démocratiquement normal
qu'une réforme d'une telle ampleur
arrive qu'à tracer un mois avant la fin
d'une mandature non je pense que ça
serait un déni de démocratie
un déni de démocratie erwan tison quelle
est votre position sur ce calendrier est
ce que vous dites
il ya urgence et on doit quand même la
faire dans les prochains mois tout
d'abord il faut savoir que tous les
soucis structurels qu'il avait acquis
j'ai justifier une réforme des retraites
en 2018 ils sont toujours là le système
est profondément déséquilibré même si le
corps nous dit que pour les prochaines
et quelques prochaines années ça va
aller un peu mieux
il ya toujours une forte inégalité entre
les retraités eux-mêmes je rappelle que
l'espérance de vie entre un ouvrier et
un cadre alentours de 6 à 7 ans il ya
une profonde iniquité entre les
générations
personne n'est dans les années 40 va
recevoir va toucher à peu près de deux
fois plus à une fois à la retraite
qu'une personne née dans les années 90
par rapport à ce qu'elle a cotisé et
enfin il ya une profonde inefficacité
financières du système qui dû justement
au système par répartition qui fait
l'économiste patrick artus l'avait
rappelé 1 pour un euro investi en 1981
vous récoltez 2 euros aujourd'hui dans
le système par répartition 20 euros dans
le système par capitalisation
donc il a effectivement urgence à
réformer système des retraites parce que
on a des systèmes qu'il est moins
efficace de l'union européenne et on a
malheureusement le système le plus
coûteux
par contre je ne pense pas qu'il faille
justement cette réforme là une forme qui
soit uniquement avec une borne d'âge
parce que faire toucher uniquement à
l'âge de départ uniquement pour les
salariés du privé sans toucher aux
régimes spéciaux
ça serait profondément injuste d'une
part et ça ne corrige rire en rien les
problématiques que jeanne soulevé que
seule une réforme systémique pourrait
réaliser
françois-xavier olivo encore une
question assure ce timing est aussi un
enjeu politique pour emmanuel macron
s'est montré qu'il est un président
réformiste qu'il a fait des réformes sur
ce quinquennat et donc c'est pour ça
qu'ils laissent planer le doute sur une
éventuelle réforme des retraites avant
la fin de son quinquennat
mais je comprends la journée politique
et le souhait de pareilles thomas
réformateur les autres intervenants ont
raison et qu'il a vécu c'est pas
forcément une bonne idée d'aller triste
et très fort nouvelle crue paramétrique
est donc parti sur un sujet aussi les
trois indices ont repris sur mtv dans le
système est vraiment qui la chasse on a
conçu ce système
au contraire il faut vraiment son destin
présidentiel pour reposer les choses à
plat pour que chacun se positionne
japonais se positionne sur la façon dont
ils souhaitent aborder le système d'
obscène et qu'on puisse effectivement
plutôt utilisé seulement séparent de la
présidentielle comme un temps de 1
moment débat et de réflexion
aucun moment de de précipitation pour
une réforme effectivement en doublant
cancer par les faibles au regard des de
la spécialité philippe dallier alors
comment expliquer qu emmanuel macron
elle laisse planer le doute sur le
calendrier de cette réforme et même que
le ministre de l'économie bruno le maire
pousse pour
à faire dans les prochains mois il ya
aussi une volonté politique finalement
de devancer la droite avant la
présidentielle et de faire cette réforme
des retraites
peut-être que c'est du calcul politique
enfin je pense que sur un sujet aussi
important pour les français on ferait
bien de dire regardée à deux fois et d'y
réfléchir parce qu'effectivement la
vraie question maintenant au delà du
timing c'est quelle réforme un je rejoue
rappelle qu' on est parti d'une annonce
devait aller vers un régime universel
par points qui effaçait toutes les
différences au fils du temps des mois on
s'est aperçu que on allait sortir de
cette réforme un tas de un tas de
personnes parce qu'on ne pouvait pas y
arriver
donc à la fin mais on savait plus très
bien que de quelle réforme on parlait et
si maintenant c'est pour passer aux
réformes uniquement paramétrique en
repoussant l'âge de départ
honnêtement ça me semble pas être non
plus la bonne formule donc je pense
qu'il faut du temps pour imaginer le
temps de la concertation pour dialoguer
avec les partenaires sociaux avec les
français donc franchement prendre cette
décision dans le week-end pour nous
annoncer lundi son savoir où on va avec
une opposition quasi radicale des bd des
partenaires sociaux je trouve que ce
serait un risque politique énorme mais à
côté de ça tous les cas je le crois
profondément ce pays a besoin de
réformes
c'est à dire que on atteindra à 2700 de
1800 milliards d'euros de dette publique
à la fin de l'année ça n'est pas
soutenable et le drame dans ce pays
c'est qu'il n'ait jamais temps de faire
des réformes il ya toujours une bonne
raison de les repousser
pour place pour le coup attendons la
présidentielle mais il faudra bien sûr
un coup d'accélérateur dès que le
nouveau gouvernement sera en place parce
que ce pays ne peut pas continuer à
dépenser l'argent qu'il n'a pas et en
reportant tout cela sur les générations
à venir ces essais c'est irresponsable
de notre part on va en parler dans un
instant du contenu de cette réforme des
retraites après la présidentielle
mais d'abord on va aller en salle des
conférences du sénat retrouver style
jourdain qui est avec le sénateur
communiste
éric bocquet weary bloqué bonjour merci
d'être avec nous j'alignerai hier
lisez au sommet entre syndicats patronat
pour l'instant pas de prise officielle
de parole des manuels mâcon sur un
éventuel retour de cette réforme des
retraites comment vous interprétez vous
ce silence du chef de l'état il est
hésitant il sent bien que l'opinion
n'est pas favorable cette réforme des
retraites les sondages le montrent aucun
syndicat aucun syndicat les salariés
n'est favorable à cette réforme même le
medef dit que c'est pas le moment ils
sont est d'accord sur le fond mais en
termes d'opportunités c'est vraiment pas
le moment on est à peine sorti de cette
pandémie qui a fait des dégâts au niveau
social la pauvreté qui a augmenté 8 %
des retraités aujourd'hui vivent sous le
seuil de pauvreté dans ce pays et on
voudrait avancer vers cette retraite
cette réforme des retraites soit disant
pour apporter la justice spéciale
inverse qui va se produire diminution
des pensions et on s'attaque à un pilier
de notre république et de notre contrat
social
franchement dans ce contexte là je me
demande si ce prêt dans la république
est bien connecté à la société qu'il est
censé présider vos visites à maintenant
ou pas du tout c'est très chaud dit pas
du tout la vraie question de fond sur ce
sujet c'est là dessus qu'on a interrogé
le gouvernement sur manière c'est de
savoir quelle part de richesse on est
prêt à consacrer à ce système de
retraite par répartition qui est le plus
juste qui soit certains voudraient nous
amener à un système par capitalisation
un système individualiste ça c'est la
fin de la solidarité c'est la fin de la
société ce système par répartition a de
l'avenir dès lors qu'on y consacre les
moyens qu'il faut est ce que ces moyens
existent nous sommes convaincus que oui
si maniema conditionné de remettre cette
réforme
à l'ordre du jour pour le town qu'est ce
que vous allez faire vous allez dans la
rue alors c'est honteux crépel mouvement
social en tout cas nous dans notre pour
notre part nous mais elle craint
effectivement la reprise est sentie
aussi vous savez toutes les fractures
c'est ce c est profondément fracturé les
gilets jaunes ça n'a pas disparu mais
les causes qui ont amené ce phénomène
sont là les inégalités se sont aggravées
au terme de cette peau de z pandémie pas
encore achevée donc il ya un risque
effectivement de révolte de mouvement
social fort parce que majoritairement
encore une fois l'opinion est opposé à
ce système la ccl structurants dans
notre société le système de retraite par
répartition
les gens ils sont profondément attachés
donc il faut vraiment s'attacher à mener
les choses de belle manière
et en tirant vers le haut le relèvement
de l'âge de départ à la retraite à 64 65
ans après la présidentielle pour vous
c'est aussi non c'est non de toute
manière on a lancé franchement on a mis
dans la tête des gens l'idée qu'il n'y a
plus d'argent dans cette société pour
financer notre modèle social et donc le
stand des retraites
cette réforme des retraites fait partie
de la feuille de route de bruxelles
notamment à l'endroit du gouvernement
français qui s'y conforme avec beaucoup
de sel
ça fait passer des réformes
structurelles qui sont exigées par
bruxelles par les marchés financiers
on peut y ajouter également la réforme
de l'assurance chômage tout cela fait
partie de la feuille de route de ce
président et je pense qu'ils auraient
regardé à deux fois avant de s'engager
de manière imprudente sur ce sujet en
quelques mots ce sujet devra être au
centre de la campagne présidentielle
selon vous avec d'autres oui avec
d'autres ça fait partie des sujets de
société de demain et qu'on nous
embarrasse pas que des questions
subalternes celle là fait partie des
questions de fond merci beaucoup à vous
et merci à mes questions
merci beaucoup ch'ti une question de
fond sur la réforme des retraites une
question parce qu'ils se posent
également faut-il vraiment rééquilibrer
les comptes de nos retraites car quand
on regarde les chiffres du cor du
conseil d'orientation des retraites et
ses prévisions on voit qu'elles sont
finalement moins alarmiste que prévu un
déficit de 13 milliards en 2020 2021 une
estimation de déficit de 10 milliards
d'euros alors qu'on parlait de 25
milliards d'euros
et puis quand on prend un peu de hauteur
de vue en 2023 et bien le déficit se
réduira et même en 2070 pendant
plusieurs décennies le régime des
retraites serait excédentaire
erwan tison finalement quand on regarde
les chiffres est ce qu'il y à vraiment
nécessité à faire cette réforme des
retraites
oui je leur réponds parce que pour moi
le l'angle budgétaire n'est pas n'est
pas suffisant vous avez observé le corps
avait fait une prévision en 2019 vous
avez un scénario qui s'appelait le
scénario de tmc qui évalue est en fait
une perte de 35 milliards à l'horizon
2030 donc ça reste fluctuant ce qu'on
sait c'est qu'on a on va avoir un creux
un creux générationnel à partir de 2028
ce que vous avez quand même pas mal de
retraités qui vont partir à la retraite
et moi je pense que au delà de ceux de
se fixer sur le côté sur le côté
déficitaire d'ailleurs on devrait pas se
satisfaire d'avoir une assurance qui est
déficitaire
un autre service pourquoi pas mais une
assurance doit pas réparé par
essence être équilibré je pense qu'il
faut aussi qu'on regarde on se poser la
question comment cela se fait-il qu'on
ait quatre points de dépenses en plus
que la plupart de nos voisins européens
tout en ayant un système qui est
beaucoup moins efficace un petit chiffre
si vous me le permettez le taux de
remplacement en france c'est à dire le
montant de la pension vous touchez par
rapport à votre dernier salaire est
environ 2 57%
il va être amené à terme en 2030 à 46%
c'est à dire qu'on fait on va voir une
diminution tendancielle de nos retraites
quand vous regardez un pays comme le
pays bas par exemple les pays bas ils
ont 105 % de taux de remplacement tout
simplement comment est ce qu'ils
arrivent à faire parce qu'ils ont un peu
qu'un pied capitalisation donc je dis
pas qu'il faut tout casser complètement
le système de répartition comme dame
dire monsieur mais je pense qu'on
pourrait profiter de notre excédent
budgétaire par rapport à nos voisins
européens c'est à dire c'est 4 points de
pib pour les transformer progressivement
d'un système de répartition d'un stand
par capitalisation c'est comme ça qu'on
arrivera d'une part à équilibrer notre
notre assurance retraite
d'autre part à pouvoir avoir une
meilleure et nikki théâtre rêvé équité
part d'entre les générations et
troisièmement de pouvoir augmenter les
pensions de retraites des retraités pour
éviter d appauvrir à l'avenir comme le
temps en train de le faire le système
par répartition
monique lubin est-ce qu'il ya urgence
vraiment à rééquilibrer les comptes des
retraites alors moi je suis membre du
corps et non je le le rapport vous
l'avez sous les yeux du moins en partie
si on ne regarde effectivement que les
effets de déficit en fonction des
différents scénarii c'est ce qu'il faut
expliquer et je pense que ça n'est pas
suffisamment fait le corps il
il fait humaine des travaux de réflexion
c'est pas à madame irma le corps 1 il
mène des travaux de réflexion en
fonction de différents scénarii et il a
donc différentes prévisions sur
différentes échelles et selon que l'on
veuille être alarmiste ou pas alarmiste
on prend le pire ou on prend le meilleur
bond mais en tout état de cause si on se
réfère au dernier rapport
il n'y a pas une urgence immédiate au
niveau de ce qui serait un déficit 1 /
mental par contre ce qui est certain
c'est que dans un horizon d'ici une
dizaine d'années on on sait que le
montant des retraites va diminuer non
non pas le montant brut des retraites
mais le plat valeur des retraites par
rapport aux
salaires des actifs comme andy le
pouvoir d'achat des retraités
diminuerait donc effectivement je
rejoins monsieur bockel quand il dit que
la question à se poser c'est de savoir
quelle part de richesse et j'ai entendu
monsieur d'allier dire de dette
quelle part de richesse on consacre aux
retraites c'est ça la vraie question
alors moi je ne dis pas qu'il ne faut
pas de réforme
je dis qu'il faut poser tout sur la
table et et avec les partenaires sociaux
et réfléchir à la façon dont on peut
sauvegarder un système de retraite qui
maintiennent un niveau de vie tout à
fait décent à tous les retraités
je suis quand même un peu étonné
d'entendre que notre système de
retraites ne serait pas bon si on le
compare aux autres systèmes européens
moi j'ai quand même beaucoup entendu au
moment où il est question de mettre en
place la réforme systémique que voulez
monsieur macron j'ai entendu beaucoup
d'européens nous dire mais pourquoi
voulez vous toucher à votre système de
retraite qui vous donne quand même un
niveau de vie tout à fait décent lorsque
vous ne travaillez plus alors monsieur
nous nous cite les pays bas enfin moi je
suis allé je suis allé à copenhague où
où les gens travaillent pour beaucoup
jusqu'à 75 ans pour avoir un niveau de
retraite des sens et on n'est pas dans
les pays qui est pour les budgets
sociaux les plus les moindres on va dire
françois-xavier haut niveau quel est
l'enjeu finalement de toucher à notre
système des retraites esprit un enjeu
budgétaire ou est ce qu'il ya un enjeu
de pouvoir d'achat pour nos retraités
une question de justice 2 parce que le
système ne marche pas le système
fondamentalement faux c'est parce qu'on
a la france ont donné une des vidéos
c'est une pratique et surtout fait poser
l'ensemble du poids des retraites sur le
travail
il le sera dans les tours travaille le
moins semblant pour big three ont
travaillé l'autre admis leurs parents là
par an après la guerre on travaille
autour de 400 heures il donne son
travail ne cesse de diminuer et on a
deux
façon qu'on a un système qui ne
fonctionne pas et qu'il faut c'est
structurellement et lui la seule voix me
semble ainsi pour sortir de cette espèce
de bulle stérile
il ya d'un côté des gens qu'il faut
travailler plus les seules solutions
avec optimisme la question il faut
trouver des moyens de financement mais
finalement c'est pas lesquelles la seule
façon de faire c'est de se dire mais
qu'est ce qui crée de la valeur
aujourd'hui dans l'écho du baiia le
travail est irritable ou qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire pour utiliser les revenus du
capital pour payer les retraites c'est
ça la question diriez vous que jean
jaurès à la pause en 1909 dans
l'humanité il disait utilisons effet les
revenus des entreprises pour payer les
retraites était il est la plus mobilisée
cette recette par capitalisation
donc jean jaurès en 1909 dans les
colonnes de l'image du ray vous à
l'époque c'est à dire un jour là de
débats préconisé on ne sait pas très
bien mais les à la retraite par
capitalisation je pense qu'il faut qu'on
écoute le reste ils comprennent que la
retraite par capitalisation ça c'est du
bon sens c'est juste le fait d'utiliser
les profits les entreprises au profit de
retraités la plupart des pays des grands
pays elles font ils le font pour leur
grand bonheur parce qu'effectivement les
chiffres absolument objectif et je
rejoins totalement évident là dessus
vous rendement de notre système de cette
échelle le redis c'est donc moins une
voix et données du gain que dans les
pays qui la cité comme dans la plupart
des pays du monde utilisent
effectivement il restait minorité dation
en paiement de la répartition et donc on
a effectivement l'espoir qu'une telle se
reposer la question de se dire
finalement est ce que les profits du cac
40 que beaucoup dénoncent au roi raison
mais s'ils pensent qu'ils pourraient pas
être réalisés pour bilan traite
comment ce qu'on met en place un système
qui permet de le faire et en fait ça
existe partout dans le monde
mettons en place et on sait là cette
solution très objectivement pour sortir
de cette impasse et critique dure depuis
30 40 ans et on a créé la csg on sait
bien que le système ait deux équipes du
crin pour leur équilibre et leur
artificier
donc on sait ça marche pas et nous
admettons le et si le réparer la
question de façon systémique et pas il
ya pas de façon paramétrique pour faire
un réglage de plus philippe dallier
emmanuel macron voulait changer le
système et faire un régime universel de
retraite avec une retraite par points
vous
croyez-vous à ce régime universel je n'y
ai jamais vraiment cru je pense que le
président de la république au fil des
mois s'est rendu compte que c'était la
réforme impossible d'en vouloir placer
tout le monde sous la même toise avec le
même régime si on était parti de rien et
qu'on invente un système qui
n'existaient pas peut-être mais à partir
du moment où on était face à des
situations extrêmement différentes
c'était c'était trop compliqué alors ce
qu'il ne faut pas dire que une prochaine
réforme ne devra pas cherché à
rééquilibrer à sa trempe de choses pour
que les disparités effectivement autres
régimes soient les moins importantes
possibles maintenant les idées simples
qui consiste à dire sa facette très
française ça d'ailleurs tout le monde
sous la même toise à égalité complète
on a bien vu que ça n'était pas que ça
n'était pas praticable alors quelle
serait la solution est ce qu'il faut
aller chercher les revenus des
entreprises moi j'en ai lancé les
retraites je vais juste rappeler que
nous sommes dans le pays où les
prélèvements obligatoires sont les
quasiment les fins les plus importants
des pays occidentaux à de l'oscd donc on
est le pays où on prélève le plus de
taxes et d'impôts et malgré ça on met le
pays sur lequel on est bientôt à 2800
milliards d'euros de dette publique et
nos régimes ne sont pas à léquilibre que
ce soit la sécurité sociale que ça soit
les retraites par l'opa du budget de
l'état donc c'est ça la situation et et
mois ci si la présidentielle doivent
servir à quelque chose c'est qu'il faut
faire prendre conscience à nos
compatriotes que ça ne peut pas
continuer ainsi et qu'il faut aller vers
un rééquilibrage de leurs comptes
publics
parce que sinon ça finira très mal alors
je n'ai pas la solution qui lui
permettrait de craquer dans les lois
elles régler le problème mais si les
français non j'entendais dire les ya un
sondage qui montre que 90 % des français
sont opposés à toute réforme mais fait
un sondage pour leur demander aux
français s'ils veulent partir à 55 ans
vous verrez que vous aurez 90% des gens
qui répondent oui mais la question c'est
pas celle là c'est comment on finance
tout ça et quelle montagne de lettres en
étendant les élus de laisser à nos
enfants
donc j'espère que le débat pendant la
présidentielle permettra d'éclairer les
français et qu'on bout du compte on fera
un choix raisonnable
on va parler d'autres réformes dans
l'agenda des manuels accroc en cette fin
de quinquennat notamment de la réforme
de l'assurance chômage qui a été
appliqué partiellement à partir du
1er juillet mais il ya une mesure
importante qui pour l'instant est un peu
en suspens c'est le nouveau mode de
calcul des allocations chômage une
mesure bloqué par le conseil d'état
vraiment critiqué par les syndicats
alors que là on voit l'ensemble des
mesures qui sont appliquées au 1er
juillet sauf ce nouveau mode de calcul
des allocations chômage mais le
gouvernement persiste sur ce point et va
quand même mettre en place la mesure
à l'automne on va écouter la ministre du
travail elisabeth bornes qui était la
semaine dernière au sénat et qui
explique pourquoi le gouvernement
persiste sur cette réforme de
l'assurance chômage
nous souhaitons réformer le système pour
le rendre plus juste
je rappelle que la location est
aujourd'hui calculé en fonction des
revenus des jours travaillés et non du
revenu moyen sur la période
cela peut conduire un demandeur d'emploi
qui a travaillé précédemment par exemple
un jour sur deux en bénéficier d'une
allocation quasiment du double par
rapport à celui qui travaille tous les
jours à mi temps alors que les deux ont
travaillé le même nombre d'heures le
montant global des droits auxquels
peuvent prétendre les demandeurs
d'emploi restera inchangé si le montant
mensuel de l'allocation pourra être
moins élevée alors le demandeur d'emploi
sera indemnisée plus longtemps ce qui
pourra lui donner le temps de rebondir
vers un emploi plus stable
monique lubin le gouvernement estime que
finalement cette réforme de l'assurance
chômage ne va pas faire baisser les
droits des demandeurs d'emploi vous
n'êtes pas d'accord je crois non c'est
mathématique quand vous prenez une somme
que vous l'a divisé par 30 au lieu de la
diviser par parvint forcément
elle sera moins importante et donc
madame la ministre nous explique que
certes l'indemnisation mensuel du summer
sera moins importante mais que ça durera
plus longtemps
sauf que le sommer qui est un citoyen il
à ben son son budget à régler j'ai envie
de dire à gérer et s'il a une
organisation qui est moins importante
dans l'immédiat ça lui posera
immanquablement des problèmes de niveau
de vie donc est l'exemple qui est citée
par madame la ministre mais je veux dire
dans dans dans toutes les décisions que
vous prenez vous pouvez toujours aller
chercher l'exemple on va dire qui sort
du lot pour généraliser quand on veut
tuer son chien on dit qu'il a la rage
voilà donc là il faut impérativement
stigmatiser les demandeurs d'emploi dont
on nous explique que la plupart d'entre
eux n'ont pas envie de retrouver un
emploi et que pour les renvoyer vers
l'emploi eh bien il faut baisser leurs
indemnités
l'organisation parce qu'en fait c'est ça
que l'on ne nous dit pas clairement mais
c'est ça qui est sous jacent c'est
pareil d'ailleurs pour la réforme des
retraites
quand on nous dit on va rallonger de
deux ans mais si on rallonge de deux ans
l'a immédiatement ça va concerner qui ça
va concerner des gens qui sont prêts à
partir à 62 ans dont on cotise est
depuis plus de 40 ans qui aux coupes qui
occupent les emplois souvent et moins
intéressant on va dire et les moins bien
rémunérés
au final ce que je constate c'est que
les efforts on lui demande toujours même
toujours erwan tison est ce que le
gouvernement a raison de persister dans
cette réforme de l'assurance chômage qui
était bien à faire baisser les
allocations de certains demandeurs
d'emploi en sortie de crise sanitaire
oui alors juste pour a pour rebondir sur
ce que madame la sénatrice alors que ça
paraisse pas un cas isolé
ce qu'on appelle la paire mi temps c'est
à dire le fait de pouvoir effectivement
cumulé des allocations et puis une
activité une activité salariale hunting
professionnel ça concerne huit cent
cinquante mille personnes sur 3,7
millions de demandeurs d'emploi donc on
n'est pas sur quelque chose de marginal
à on est vraiment sur un sur l'épaisseur
du trait et c'est ça quelque part qui
qui qui qui déstructure notre notre
notre
équilibre fortement notre système qui là
encore est anase une assurance je le
répète on n'est pas sur le cas du nahd
et nos vocations comme comme pourrait
être le rsa ou comme quoi être autre
chose qu'il a c'est pas grave s'il ya un
petit déficit structurel var
conjoncturel mais là on est sur une
assurance chômage l'assurance chômage
doit pas mécanisme être parfaitement
équilibré donc c'est à dire que pourquoi
elle doit être équilibrée pour permettre
de créer des déficits en cas de
récession et pour permettre de créer des
excédents en période de croissance il se
trouve en fait que la réforme que veut
faire le gouvernement
elle est à ce titre dans le cas de la
lutte pour la permanence une bonne chose
je regrette par contre ils pas qu'ils
aient pas eu la promesse initiale du
président de la république qui étaient
celles effectivement d'ouvrir des droits
ou de mots démissionnaire qui permettait
en fait d'avoir un peu plus de
flexibilité de fluidité sur le marché du
travail
par contre sur la sur la question sur la
question de la temporalité
il faut bien savoir que la réforme est
pas prévu pour rentrer tout de suite en
tout cas pas dans tout son bloc en
vigueur dès ce soir il ya la volonté des
tirs et un petit peu et de faire part
pas quelques ordonnances des exceptions
pour essayer d'aller chercher juste
après la crise l'idée c'est qu'en fait
de se dire en période de reprise on
pourra avoir une réforme qui incite au
travail et qui permettent tout
simplement en fait d'aveux de corriger
les dysfonctionnements qui sont
aujourd'hui trop couteau c'est un petit
peu la logique qui a derrière alors
l'arrivée je pense cette intemporalité
bonne oui parce que la réforme est
parfaite non il reste encore quelques
points à améliorer mais au moins ça va
dans le bon sens françois-xavier au
niveau là aussi est ce qu'on est dans le
symbole pour emmanuel macron avec cette
réforme de l'assurance chômage pourrait
bien montrer qu'il a mené des réformes
jusqu'au bout on est sur une réforme qui
reste une question d'importance pour
garder une session positive aux gens qui
ont travaillé et je pense qu'une
génération une complexité absolument
insondable du nom système social et dans
cette europe est cité je pense comment
sous-estiment le bêlement l'autre elle
est issue de deux décennies de
d'empilement de mesures sans forcément
de cohérence les unes avec les autres et
là encore ça c'est vraiment je suis
partisan d'une réflexion un peu
systémique
j'ai bien finalement est ce que c'est la
meilleure façon de le faire le principal
coût de 16 de cette complexité d'abord
ce sont les plus précaires qui le kiki
qu'il subisse un le nom de guichet qui
sont obligés de les voir et le nombre la
complexité de leur parcours rapide
inhumaine vraiment j'ai fait que poser
la question de savoir comment seront
faits ainsi celle qui soit vraiment
collectif qui soit non des incitatifs
parce que dans plusieurs cas les faits
il ya du telle qu'elle est de droit
quand vous reprenez une activité que
l'incitation à l'activité
peut-être parfois très faible en france
et donc on a inventé des trappes à
édicter rod et où on pousse des gens qui
seraient contents de travailler pas ne
pas travailler
donc ça a été un peu corrigé récemment
avec correction sur des sur l'esthétisme
et la gauche et je pense qu'il faut
vraiment là aussi on repenser notre
façon de de donner à chacun la liberté
de travail et contribuer au marché du
travail mais en refaisant menant une
réflexion du sang sur la façon dont on
accompagne ces personnes-là est dans une
logique de simplification je suis un
ancien d'industrie au débat et on
faisait ce qu'on appelle ville
manufacturing a d'abord on arrange tous
ont tout ce qui existe en leur on le
remet en cause et on repart c'est
quelque chose qui est beaucoup plus
simple qui part du besoin des gens qui
parlent de l'institution qui est
organisée autour des personnes nées
autour de leurs parcours
évitez le roi monumentale de la
complexité dont ils doivent subir tous
les jours les les conséquences et on
reconstruit quelque chose autour d'eux
mais là encore de façon encore une fois
le débat présidentiel et la bonne
occasion de le faire c'est moi beaucoup
plus important que de faire les
ajustements à la marge
merci merci françois xavier olivo merci
à tous les cas d'avoir participé à ce
débat philippe dallier je finis juste
par une question personnelle vous avez
décidé de quitter le sénat après 17 ans
de mandat pour qui la décision
j'ai été élu conseiller départemental le
27 juin donc je devais choisir entre art
et ses parlementaires c'est la loi sur
le non-cumul voit ses parlementaires ou
conserver mes mandats locaux donc j'ai
choisi de conserver mes mandats locaux
qu'est-ce que vous retiendrez de ses 17
ans de mandat au sénat 17 très belles
années dans une maison où on peut
travailler et on travaille et ce sera le
mot de la fin
merci beaucoup à dans 30 minutes à ce
sera le début des questions d'actualité
au gouvernement toute notre équipe est
en place avec steve jourdain aux
interviews en salle des conférences
j'en acier notre streamer politique qui
va commenter cette séance sur twitch et
puis notre commentateur en tribune de
presse de l'hémicycle du sénat quand un
calme et quentin on va
beaucoup d'écologie durant cette séance
de questions au gouvernement est
exactement l ex 1 on attend plusieurs
questions sur ce thème de l'écologie
tout d'abord deux questions venu de la
gauche de l'hémicycle les sénateurs
socialistes est également écologistes
veulent interroger le gouvernement sur
l'ultimatum qui a été publiée la semaine
dernière par le conseil d'état le
conseil d'état qui juge que la
trajectoire de la réduction des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre du
gouvernement n'est pas la bonne
vous le savez un depuis la coop 21 la
france est engagée à réduire de 40% ses
émissions de co2 d'ici l'année 2030 par
rapport aux niveaux de 1990 et le
conseil d'état a donné jusqu'au 31 mars
à l'exécutif pour revoir sa copie dans
cette trajectoire 31 vincent ça va
tomber pile pendant à la campagne
présidentielle donc ça s'annonce comme
un débat très intéressant à suivre dans
les prochains mois autre question sur ce
sujet on va voir un échange et sera
d'ailleurs la toute première question
d'actualité aujourd'hui autour de
l'abandon du référendum sur
l'introduction à l'article 1 de la lutte
est bien en faveur du climat on a
compris hier que le gouvernement avait
décidé d'abandonner cette réforme après
la nouvelle réécriture par le sénat
lundi 2 est bien ce qu il faudrait
écrire dans l'article 1
il ya donc un désaccord après quatre
débats au parlement sur ce qu'il faut
écrire à l'article 1 il ya donc comme
cela une impasse politique entre les
deux chambres du parlement et donc on
voit que depuis hier depuis lundi le
gouvernement accuse la droite et le
centre
ici au sénat d'être alors tantôt climato
sceptiques ou en tout cas d'avoir fait
échouer cette révision constitutionnelle
en philippe bas pour les allait reposer
la toute première question aujourd'hui
sur ce sujet on s'attend donc à l'ex à
ce que à 15h sur ce thème là le ton
monte tout de suite donc en ouverture de
séance à l'excellent oui oui les
échanges vous êtes un petit peu tendu
autour de l'échec de ce référendum sur
le climat on va maintenant parler de la
présidentielle 2022 avec une question
comment désigner le candidat de la
droite et du centre à la présidentielle
faut-il organiser une primaire de la
droite et du centre
ou alors se ranger derrière
le candidat qui est le mieux placé dans
les sondages pour éviter un duel
emmanuel macron marine le pen au second
tour c'est-à-dire xavier bertrand pour
le moment le ce sera donc l'objet de
notre face à face avec aujourd'hui sur
ce plateau olivier paccaud vous êtes
sénateur de l'oise rattaché au groupe
l'est républicain du sénat et vous êtes
soutien de xavier bertrand
bonjour bonjour adrien alexandre
alexandrov
et puis c'est y avait des soucis et puis
il accueille également philippe mouillé
sénateurs républicains des deux sèvres
et vous êtes soutien de valérie pécresse
bonjour alors avant d'ouvrir ce débat
sur une primaire à droite on va revenir
et on va voir les dernières tractations
chez les républicains autour de cette
question de la primaire en vue de la
présidentielle
les explications de jonathan du
président xavier bertrand reste
inflexible malgré la pression de son
ancienne famille politique le président
de la région haute france refuse
toujours d'être candidats à une primaire
de la droite disant craindre une machine
à perdre
je suis candidat à l'élection
présidentielle pour être président de la
république
donc c'est à dire cette rencontre entre
un homme une femme et les français sans
filtre et son primaire alors que
bertrand continue de faire cavalier seul
l'ailer temporise lors d'un bureau
politique au siège du parti hier le
président des républicains christian
jacob a maintenu un calendrier déjà
dévoilé avant les régionales
si un candidat naturel se dégage il sera
désigné lors d'un congrès en novembre
autrement en dernier recours l'ailer
organiseront une primaire nommé
processus de rassemblement
je souhaite d'abord que l'on arrive à
l'union sans cela mais si on n'y arrive
pas on n'est pas naïf on préparera ce
processus de rassemblement qui qui nous
permettra en novembre de désigner notre
candidat mais pour certains ténors
pressent le parti d'organiser une
primaire ouverte au plus vite le
calendrier de christian jacob risque de
laisser un boulevard à xavier bertrand
plus le temps passera plus celui qui en
sera le bénéficiaire c'est xavier
bertrand puisque son pari précisément
c'est ça c'est de partir plus vite de
jouer le lièvre
tous les regards se tournent désormais
vers jean leonetti
le consensus elmer d'antibes doit
plancher sur les règles du départage
il rencontrera tous les prétendants cet
été y compris xavier bertrand et on
ouvre ce face à face au tour de la
primaire à droite pour la présidentielle
philippe mouillée avant de parler de
l'intérêt à d'organiser une primaire
un mot sur le calendrier christian jacob
le patron des républicains a décidé
d'attendre la fin septembre pour se
mettre d'accord sur un processus de
désignation
est-ce que c'est pas un peu tard alors
ça peut sembler un peu tard et
d'ailleurs c'était notre première
réaction
même si clairement ça permet aussi
durant l'été qui discuteront et dialogue
entre les candidats potentiels et avec
xavier bertrand je crois que ça a été
très bien dit aujourd'hui le système de
la primaire ou de départage est une
règle qui est parfois difficile mal
vécue et que le fait d'avoir un candidat
naturel semblerait la bonne solution
voilà donc je crois que le calendrier
est un peu un peu compliqué mais dans le
contexte je crois que ça donne aussi un
espace de dialogue
oui mais pas causé le bon choix ce
calendrier attendre trois mois pour que
les prétendants la droite se met
d'accord autour d'un candidat d'ici la
fin septembre
je suis pas persuadé que ce soit le
meilleur calendrier plutôt il y aura un
candidat désigné soutenu par tout le
monde mieux ce sera mais la première des
choses que je tiens à dire c'est que que
nous soutenions xavier bertrand valérie
pécresse
nous souhaitons tous nous voulons tous
l'union ça c'est clair
les choses sont très claires et avec
philippe
il n'y a aucun souci là-dessus
maintenant moi je pense que pour
désigner ce candidat il ya trois
préalables quand même qu'on doit avoir
en tête le premier préalable au sujet de
la primaire n'en parle plus de primaires
on parle maintenant de processus de
rassemblement mais c'est que sur les dix
élections présidentielles qui se sont
déroulées depuis 1965 à savoir depuis
que les français choisissent eux-mêmes
leurs présidents y en a une seule qui a
abouti à l'élection au couronnement d'un
président sortie du primaire 2012
françois hollande sinon ça n'a jamais
été le cas donc si c'était la bonne
méthode ça serait
deuxième préalable quand même important
c'est que il y a un candidat à la
présidentielle ça faisait rêver bertrand
et il y à des candidats potentiels à la
candidature valérie pécresse que
j'apprécie beaucoup a dit qu'elle
réfléchissait laurent wauquiez n'a rien
dit très clair mais michel barnier
encore - françois baroin a dit qu'il
voulait pas y aller car que bruno
retailleau qui a été peut-être un petit
peu plus clair la subit la troisième est
là peut-être la plus importante des
choses en matière de deux préalables
c'est la détermination
celui ou celle qui va l'emporter
c'est celui ou celle qui en veut le plus
et ça on ne peut pas dénier cette
qualité de détermination qui ne doit pas
aboutir à l'ameublement
mais on ne peut pas dénier sa à xavier
bertrand alors l'alternative à
l'organisation d'une primaire c'est
qu'il y ait finalement un candidat
naturel à droite qui se dégage mais
quand on regarde les sondages et bien
sûr candidat naturel il ne se dégage pas
car avec ce sondage ifop qui est paru ce
week-end dans le journal du dimanche
avec la question qui serait un bon
candidat à droite on voit que ce serait
xavier bertrand pour 46% des français
valérie pécresse pour 42% françois
baroin 38%
bref il n'y a pas de candidat naturel
d'où l'intérêt d'une primaire
d'où l'attrait alors et puis surtout
blanc avoir qu'un point en tête ces
terres que les dernières primaires que
nous avons organisée c'est pas la
première que nous étaient pas des
élections
patrick lasseube est d'ailleurs mobilisé
un nombre important de français plus de
4 millions de choix que fouette voilà
c'est à c'est un moyen comme les autres
il est évident que dans nos familles
politiques
on souhaiterait avoir voilà quelqu'un
qui se dégage qui fait que naturellement
il ya tout le monde se s'associent
derrière lui pour on voit bien à travers
le sondage que c'était pas le cas même
si on voit bien que aujourd'hui xavier
bertrand est parti mais la détermination
gérer les 3 4
non quand et cités sont des personnes
déterminées simplement d'un côté il ya
deux stratégies différentes
un démarrer le plus vite possible pour
faire campagne et dont tact et de
l'autre côté dialoguer au sein du parti
où les partenaires du parti pour avoir
une méthode qui est proposé voilà donc
clairement aujourd'hui si vous n'avez
pas de solution et bien il vaut mieux
organiser une primaire ouverte que se
retrouver dans une situation de
difficulté parce que le point commun est
s'atténue pas olivier paccaud c'est
clair qu'aujourd'hui on souhaite avant
tout être gagné les élections et donc
être unie derrière un candidat qui se
devait être avant tout un bon capitaine
parce que ce que l'on a aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on a plein de talent on voit
bien pleins de talent de personnalités
des visions et parfois un peu différente
mais une base commune et de logique et
donc à partir de là et bien trouvons le
bon capitaine pour pouvoir mener ses
équipes à la victoire
olivier paccaud finalement ce que fait
xavier bertrand c'est un peu une course
de vitesse et partir en premier c'est la
fable du lièvre et de la tortue
oui peut-être mais en tout cas il est
parti il est préparé il est armé
il est déterminé et alors effectivement
il n'est pas pour la primaire je ne suis
pas non plus pour la primaire et je vais
vous donner trois raisons la première
des raisons c'est que une primaire c'est
censé unir
après un processus de débat de
confrontation d'idées qui va désigner
quelqu'un le problème c'est que ça peut
aussi et ça a souvent fracture est
divisée fragiliser le candidat 2017
c'est vrai que si la droite a perdu
c'est d'abord à cause d'une affaire
fillon mais il ya quand même toujours
des petites phrases
on va en parler imagine-t-on le général
de gaulle mis en examen il ya toujours
des plaies qui sont difficiles à
cicatriser
c'est la première raison la deuxième
raison c'est que lors d'une primaire on
va parler au peuple de droite ou au
peuple de gauche puis ensuite on va
devoir un peu changé son discours pour
parler à tous les français
c'est un exercice de cohérence
intellectuelle qui ne paraît pas facile
et le troisième argument celui qu'a
utilisée xavier bertrand mais qui est
tellement important dans notre histoire
politique c'est que l'élection
présidentielle sous la vème république
c'est vraiment la rencontre entre les
français et leur avenir
entre un candidat ou une candidate et le
peuple et ça ne peut pas passer par le
ça ne doit pas passer par le prisme des
parties
parce que les parties vont chercher à et
à leur place c'est logique ils vont
chercher à contrôler est en quelque
sorte imposé leur vision à ce candidat
or la boussole du candidat ce n'est pas
la droite ou la gauche c'est la france
et la primaire donne la boussole de la
droite ou la boussole de la gauche alors
que la position du candidat ça doit être
la boussole de la force
alors moi j'ai un peu nuancé par rapport
à ça ouais japonais ans parce que je
crois que certes c'est la rencontre d'un
homme et son peuple mais c'est aussi là
c'est aussi la présentation d'un projet
politique est un projet politique il
n'est pas plus droite une gauche ça veut
dire qu'au moment donné même si les mots
peut-être telle aide à la communication
et à orienter ce sont deux sensibilités
politiques
quand vous êtes dans la primaire c'est à
vous commencé à développer votre projet
politique et c'est ça qui est essentiel
et parfois on a parfois oublié que on
voit bien aujourd'hui c'est pas
simplement qu'une personnalité
c'est aussi un projet politique dont ça
c'est le premier point et je crois
capable de l'autre élément c'est que on
veut pas les difficultés de fractures
moment des primaires ont globalement
quand on connaît mieux la vie politique
d vous avez un leader et des gens qui
sont en en deuxième division
un moment donné il ya toujours des
facteurs politiques trop que tant qu'à
pâtes et de l'appeler le point essentiel
c'est celui qui est capable de porter
ses convictions de faire quelque part sa
place moi jouer à l'engagement de
valérie pécresse dans cette démarche là
et qui a aussi la capacité arrière de
fédérer et de regrouper et de faire en
sorte que ces factures biens sont
minimisés pour un objectif commun qu'ils
gagnaient la présentielle mais la
question c'est est-ce que ces primaires
n'est pas est-ce que cette primaire
n'est pas une machine divisé oubliez pas
qu vous parliez de la violence de la
première de 2010 est à droite et
justement on va revoir ce discours de
françois fillon très durs envers nicolas
sarkozy
souvenez-vous qu'est alain juppé ceux
qui briguent la confiance des français
doivent en être digne
ceux qui ne respectent pas les lois de
la république ne devrait pas pouvoir se
présenter devant les électeurs
il ne sert à rien de parler d'autorité
quand on n'est pas soi même
irréprochable
[Applaudissements]
qui qui imagine un seul instant le
général de gaulle mis en examen un
levier pas caution va dans une primaire
de la droite à ce sera nécessairement
une fracturation de votre famille
écoutez on peut des fois tirer des
enseignements du passé mais c'est vrai
que c'est toujours compliqué d'essuyer
deux rangées des sabres après les avoir
rougis dans dans une confrontation il ya
toujours des tensions des risques de
dérapage et c'est pas forcément donc une
bonne chose
néanmoins il faut pas avoir peur du
débat d'idées et comme l'a dit philippe
lachance de la grande famille gaulliste
de la droite et du centre
c'est d'avoir des talents qui incarnent
des visions peut-être un petit peu
différent des fois mais on part là on
doit pouvoir parler à tous les français
et si à mon avis xavier bertrand est
aujourd'hui le meilleur des candidats
c'est parce que il a le positionnement
qui est entre guillemets celui qui
correspond le plus à mon avis à ce
qu'attendent les français c'est à dire
le gaullisme social c'est celui et sa
victoire dans les hauts de france qui
n'est pas une région comme les autres
qui est une région qui est une petite
france où il a dû faire face à une
coalition d'opposition très forte
un front national très fort 2015 marine
le pen au premier tour est à plus de 40%
il l'a fait tomber à 25 % une terre de
gauche 2015 les deux régions qui avaient
fusionné était à gauche là sont tombés à
18%
une terre où on avait envoyé cinq
ministres marcheurs et bien il a
démontré qu'il était capable de renvoyer
dans leurs 22 entre guillemets ces
oppositions uniquement parce que il a
été un bon président de région qu'il a
bien agi et parce qu'aussi il incarne ce
qui à mon avis est ce dont les français
ont besoin
cette justice sociale cette justice
territoriale qui est vraiment sa marque
de fabrique
donc selon vous avez bertron peut
rassembler les français justement
philippe j'ai de vrais le même sentiment
vis-à-vis pécresse oui mais justement
sur la primaire est ce que le principe
d'une primaire ce n'est pas forcément
est bien de faire émerger une ligne qui
est un peu radicale et qui après ne
serait pas forcément rassembleuse sûr
et d'abord rappelons d'abord le contexte
on est tous d'accord d'une façon
générale pour dire que la première n'est
pas forcément l'outil idéal démarche
plus simple aurait été vraiment d'avoir
voilà quelqu'un qui la tuera les
sondages un candidat naturel
mobilisation est donc quelque part un
équipe qui se mobilisent dans la durée
avec avec un travail d'un projet
politique commun
bon ca s'élève aujourd'hui moi je parte
je fais le constat qu' on n'est pas dans
cette situation là et donc il faut
trouver une solution alors chacun a sa
stratégie et que la moins mauvaise
solution c'est justement de mettre en
place un outil une façon de départager
et voilà devenu et partager quelques
parler les candidats ici de christian
jacob à utiliser un autre mot que le mot
primaire c'est justement pour tirer les
enseignements de ce qui s'est passé la
dernière fois en dix ans à la règle du
jeu c'est de montrer les talents des uns
et des autres pour pouvoir faire en
sorte qu'on puisse faire un choix et
donc j'ai l'idée c'est vraiment de se
battre contre les difficultés des
mauvais mots des mauvaises phrase qui
fracturent qui crée des difficultés et
je crois qu'on a vraiment tiré des
enseignements parce que avoue le
reportage est clair à la fois les les
mots portés par françois fillon sa
situation
on vient que tout ça c'est une machine à
perdre et je crois qu'on a tiré ses
enseignements
d'une façon générale voilà donc on a
aujourd'hui une méthode qui est
enclenchée par un certain nombre de
candidats à la candidature
un candidat qui est parti lui en
campagne électorale qu à ses talents on
a vraiment la chance vraiment d'avoir
des talents mais voilà différents mais
qui ont une capacité à se mobiliser et
je crois qu'il faut à travers tout ça
prophétisé du temps de cet été pour
dialoguer discuter faire confiance à
jean leonetti pour l'organisation
déjà il va être aussi le trait d'union
entre les différents candidats parce
qu'il m'a parlé tout le monde y compris
avec xavier bertrand et on en tirera des
enseignements à la rentrée de septembre
mais voilà mais je pense que à un moment
donné la responsabilité tout le monde je
faisais vie battront où les autres
candidats ou valérie pécresse c'est
avant tout une responsabilité vis-à-vis
de cette capacité que nous avons de
cette ouverture nous avons de pouvoir
remporter l'élection présentielle
et c'est ça et je crois que là on verra
réellement gérer gérer la reconnaissance
les talents de nos de nos candidats
potentiels c'est cette capacité après tu
vas prendre ses responsabilités parce
que l'enjeu principal c'est pas lorca
la politique c'est justement la france
est donc là on a vraiment une volonté
générale et on verra si tous ces
prétendants la droite arrive à se
rassembler cet été en vue de la
présidentielle messieurs vous restez
avec nous on va évoquer les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement qui commence
dans une dizaine de minutes et on va
retrouver jean massy est le streamer
politique qui va commenter cette séance
sur la plateforme twitter avec toute sa
communauté
jean qu'est ce que les membres de la
communauté attendent de cette séance de
questions d'actualité
québec ou d'alex le sujet qui intéresse
probablement le plus et tu t'en doutes
c'est ce référendum sur le climat qui
n'aura pas lieu a été annoncée par jean
castex hier le gouvernement abandonne
donc le bras de fer avec le sénat mais
senna gagne il y aura pas de référendum
sur le climat tu te doutes bien que ça
déçoit beaucoup d'internautes qui aurait
bien aimé qu'on ne puisse avoir ce débat
à l'occasion d'un référendum
un autre sujet qui intéresse beaucoup
c'est l'assassinât du président haïtien
on l'a appris par la bouche du premier
ministre de ce pays à seulement quelques
quelques heures ça interpelle beaucoup
l'assassinât du président en exercice
c'est pas tous les jours ou peut-être
une question à jean yves le drian sur la
ce que la diplomatie française peut nous
dire de cette situation en haïti et le
troisième sujet qui intéresse beaucoup
les internautes c'est la quatrième vague
du covin on commence à en parler de plus
en plus
où en est on de la campagne de
vaccination qu'est ce que le
gouvernement met en place et surtout la
question de l'obligation vaccinale tu
t'en doutes
ça fait beaucoup de dégâts sur internet
donc voila un petit peu les sujets qu'on
attend cet après midi pour la séance des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
et oui il va être question tu le disais
gens de l'échec de ce référendum sur le
climat à cause d'un dessin d accord
entre la majorité du sénat et le
gouvernement la majorité à l'assemblée
nationale sur une réforme de la
constitution en faveur de la
préservation de l'environnement et
d'ailleurs
ce midi le porte parole du gouvernement
gabriela talent a été très dur envers la
majorité droite sénatoriale
il la voit là il a critiqué et bien son
son refus d'accepter ce référendum sur
le climat on l'écouté comme nous nous y
étions engagés nous avons repris les
propositions de la convention citoyenne
pour le climat est proposé d'inscrire la
protection de la planète dans l'article
1er de notre constitution
visiblement ni
cette proposition de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat ni l'urgence
climatique n'ont amené la majorité
sénatoriale à reprendre cette
proposition et elles l'ont amené au
contraire à refuser tout compromis sur
la question mais je veux le dire ici
nous ne céderons pas à ceux qui croient
que l'on peut se réfugier derrière des
querelles sémantiques à ceux qui pensent
que la planète peut bien attendre et que
l'écologie n'est qu'une question de
second rang nous ne leur sert en rien et
nous continuerons comme nous le faisons
depuis 2010 est amené corps et âme le
combat de l'environnement voilà pour les
critiques de gabriella talents vers la
majorité de droite sénatoriale et on va
avoir la réponse de cette majorité avec
philippe bas le sénateur les
républicains qui est en salle des
conférences avec vous c'est yves jourdan
wifi bas bonjour bonjour vous êtes sur
le banc des accusés visiblement puisque
le gouvernement
vous accusez vous et le sénat en fait
d'avoir saboté ce référendum sur le
climat la parole est à la défense
vous savez en matière constitutionnelle
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat sont
strictement à égalité de droit nous
avons voté à deux reprises
l'inscription de la protection de
l'environnement à l'article 1er de la
constitution
c'est chose faite et le gouvernement
n'est pas plus fondés à nous reprocher
de ne pas avoir recopié le texte de
l'assemblée nationale que nous ne
serions fondés à reprocher à l'assemblée
nationale de ne pas avoir repris notre
texte
la vérité c'est que le gouvernement n'a
strictement rien fait pour essayer
d'obtenir un accord il renonce en rase
campagne et je crois qu'ils privent
ainsi le pays d'un débat de fond sur la
politique écologique que nous voulons
pour la france est ce que cette la
politique du développement durable
conciliant environnement conciliant
progrès social et développement
économique
ça c'est la charte de l'environnement
urgence mais ce que je sais
l'écologie radicale l'écologie de la
décroissance qui placent au dessus de
toute autre considération politique
les préoccupations environnementales
nous sommes pour l' équilibre
la convention citoyenne le président de
la république et le gouvernement sont
pour la rupture avec le développement
durable
c'est un beau débat et je regrette
qu'ils ne puissent avoir lieu jusqu'au
bout mais je suis tranquille c'est la
faulx 10 au sérieux
à l'occasion de l'élection
présidentielle l'année prochaine car la
france ne peut pas passer à côté de ce
débat l'urgence climatique il faudra
l'inscrire dans la constitution selon
vous qu'est ce que ça veut dire
inscrire d'urgence climatique dans la
constitution comme je voulais dit nous
avons inscrit deux fois au titre
l'article premier de la constitution la
préservation de l'environnement mais
nous l'avons fait en préservant les
équilibres fondamentaux du développement
durable tel qu'il est prévu à la charte
de l'environnement
je ne sache pas que les français veulent
renoncer au développement durable
je crois que c'est la ligne que nous
devons suivre
quitte d'ailleurs à accélérer la mise en
oeuvre d'une politique protectrice pour
notre planète
philippe bas autres questions
d'actualité bureau politique des
républicains votre partir sur le
calendrier pour départager les candidats
éventuels à la présidentielle a été
maintenue on ne tranche pas avant le
mois de novembre est ce que vous
regrettez
et bien cette décision de votre parti je
pense au contraire que nous progressons
pas à pas l'important pour moi ce n'est
pas la méthode c'est le résultat et vous
verrez que le résultat ce sera la
désignation d'un candidat unique de la
droite et du centre pour la prochaine
élection présidentielle
nous incarnerons ainsi l'alternance nous
romprons ce dialogue impossible entre en
marche et le front national a appelé
ainsi et nous feront irruption dans le
débat pour incarner la véritable alterne
on se dirige vers une alternance
d'ailleurs dans notre pays a besoin
on se dirige vers une primaire primaires
ouvertes trimaran tour c'est ce que vous
souhaitez
comme je voulais dit pour moi
l'important c'est que tout le monde soit
d'accord sur les modalités
et que à l'issue de ce processus nous
ayons un candidat unique parce que toute
autre attitude serait évidemment
suicidaire merci beaucoup philippe
garcia vous pouvez répondre à mes
questions
merci beaucoup steve olivier paccaud
fils bas en parlait de ce désaccord sur
le fond entre le sénat et le
gouvernement sur cette révision de la
constitution en faveur du climat qui
devait être soumise à référendum c'est
la promesse d' emmanuel macron est ce
qu'au fond emmanuel macron le
connaissait ce désaccord et a tendu un
piège à la droite sénatoriale pour dire
vous le voyez les sénateurs de droite ne
sont pas écolo écouter s'il a voulu
tendre un piège à mon avis s'est pris
les pieds dans le tapis personne n'a le
monopole de la défense de
l'environnement et si gabriel attal
avait assisté aux débats qui ont pu
avoir lieu dans l'hémicycle
il aurait pu voir que sur tous les bancs
et pas seulement sur ceux de la majorité
sénatoriale ya une véritable conscience
environnementale et quand j'entends
parler monsieur attal du fait qu'il y
avait une proposition de compromis
c'est un mode on n'a pas la même
définition compromis pour le
gouvernement c'est à dire alignement il
faut que le sénat soit aligné derrière
nous avons une capacité de réflexion
nous avons une capacité de défense de
l'environnement nous nous sommes fait
entendre en tout cas il ya un sujet qui
fait plus consensus entre les sénateurs
et le gouvernement il s'agit de la
vaccination obligatoire pour les
soignants le gouvernement planche
philippe mouillé sur cette idée
notamment pour éviter une quatrième
vague de l'épidémie à cause du variant
delta est ce que vous êtes favorable
vous à cette vaccination obligatoire
pour les soignants est ce qu'il faut
même aller plus loin pour certaines à
partie de la population oui alors tout à
fait favorables et d'ailleurs on attend
un texte la fin juillet voilà on espace
à des personnes qui ont fait un choix
professionnel parfois même par vocation
et donc je trouve naturel que les
soignants soient vaccinés d'ailleurs ils
le sont pour d'autres d'autres types de
deux malades du virus donc je crois que
c'est important et c'est une logique en
même temps c'est un message parce qu'ils
ont tous à ce que le maximum de
personnes soient vaccinés voilà les deux
quelque part il faut que les soignants
aussi montre l'exemple
voilà donc pour moi c'est un point
essentiel est la question se pose
éventuellement sur d'autres catégories
je pense tout ce qu'il ce qui est à
l'aide à domicile
pourquoi pas quelques enseignes enfin la
question doit se poser
en tous les cas je crois que la toune
lieu ni sur le fait de dire aujourd'hui
il faut mettre en place tous les atouts
toutes les possibilités pour éviter une
quatrième vague et que ce que le virus
se repartent et nous perturbe
mais pour évoquer cette vaccination
obligatoire on va aller en salle des
conférences retrouver steve jourdain qui
est avec patrick kanner le président du
groupe socialiste au sénat
oui patrick kanner bonjour merci d'être
avec nous jean castex réunit demain les
élus locaux en pour acter ou non la
vaccination obligatoire pour les
soignants vous dites quoi ça y est
follet faut y aller vers cette
vaccination obligatoire
le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicaine a délibéré en ce sens hier
mais dans une volonté de non
stigmatisation des soignants et on les a
applaudis faut pas les oublier
pendant des semaines pendant le premier
confinement aujourd'hui il faut les
respecter
s'il faut il faut vacciner les soignants
il faut qu'il se vaccine une manière
directives si nécessaire mais pas en
stigmatisant ce corps parce que
aujourd'hui
finalement c'est pas cette vaccination
qui arrêtera la quatrième vague qui se
prépare malheureusement il ya bien donc
d'autres mesures qui doivent être prises
notamment en direction de près de
presque 30% des français qui aujourd'hui
ne sont pas encore vaccinés patrick
kanner xavier bertrand propose
aujourd'hui d'étendre le pass sanitaires
et de l'exigé par exemple à l'entrée des
restaurants bonne mauvaise idée le pass
à lithaire c'est finalement la preuve
qu' on n'est plus contagieux et qu'on
est protégée de la maladie et donc là
aussi notre groupe a pensé que puisque
cet outil maintenant existe et qu'il
était intégrée par l'ensemble des
citoyens ayant été vaccinés ils puissent
en bénéficier pour accéder à des
libertés qui peut être demain seront
restreintes à cause d'un quatrième
clairement à ce qu'il faut restreindre
les libertés pour ceux qui ne sont pas
vaccinés selon groulx s'agit pas de
restreindre liberté il s'agit lui dire
que ce qu'ils ont fait non pas les
formes et qui ont pris la responsabilité
d'être vacciné puissent vivre
normalement on ne peut pas imaginer que
dans un quatrième confinement cet outil
que représente le passé militaire soit
mis de côté ce serait totalement
incompris
nos concitoyens donc il faut l'étendre
c'est le foot il faut l'étendre de
manière mesurée de manière concertée
mais en faire un outil utile pour la vie
en société
patrick kanner une certaine anne hidalgo
étaient hier au sénat qu'est ce qu'elle
est venu vous dire ça y est elle est
candidate elle n'est pas candidate
pas encore officiellement pas encore
elle est venue rencontrer pendant près
de trois heures dans ce qu'on appelle
dans notre jargon le pot de fin de
session du groupe socialiste un
mouvement se crée autour de dan dah
gosset manifeste des locaux de
parlementaires mais aussi de citoyens
les choses iront à leur rythme et anne
hidalgo choisira le moment où elle
déclarera peut-être sa candidature en
tout cas il ya manifestement un
alignement des planètes autour de la
démarche qu'elle a entamée qui se
poursuit aujourd'hui qui va se
poursuivre pendant l'été mais soyons
patients c'est une halte à marathon
l'élection présidentielle qui se termine
par un 110 m haies mais faut déjà être
bien dans ces cas-là on apprend quand
même dans le canard enchaîné aujourd'hui
qu'il existe au sein de la mairie de
paris une cellule chargée en quelque
sorte de rameuter les troupes en faveur
de cette candidature anne hidalgo
l'appel dont vous parlez
vous parlez et qui a été lancé la
semaine dernière par les 200 élus locaux
en faveur de cette candidature à ce
qu'il était vraiment spontané cet appel
la peine a été portée y compris par moi
même où jean françois lebas le maire de
beaucamps vrai ce sont des élus qui se
mobilisent pour cette candidature
bien sûr pour un sens un projet
politique mais qu'elle puisse se
déclarer au bon moment donc aujourd'hui
le canard enchaîné a fait ces
découvertes habituel ce que je sais
c'est que la campagne n'est pas encore
lancée il faut garder notre calme
merci beaucoup patrick hemmer merci
d'avoir répondu à mes questions on va
tout de suite retrouvé quand un calme et
dans l'hémicycle quentin donnez nous le
programme oui merci steve alors que vous
voyez un jet à arracher à quitter le
bureau de départ pour rejoindre
l'hémicycle arrivé derrière moi d'un
instant à l'autre et vous l'avez compris
il va être largement question
aujourd'hui d'écologie la toute première
question va être posée par philippin
votre invité style bien instant on va
revenir sur cet abandon par le
gouvernement de la révision
constitutionnelle qui devait inscrire
dans l'article 1 la lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique met donc on l'a
bien compris et le gouvernement accusent
le sénat d'être à l'origine de l'abandon
de cette révision constitutionnelle on
va voir deux autres questions sur le
conseil d'état on voit sur des questions
posées par les médecins du sénat que ce
soit le groupe socialiste le groupe
lr horreur des sénateurs qui sont
médecins qui vont poser des questions
sur l'obligation nationale ou encore sur
la lutte contre le variant delta donc il
va encore être largement question de
crise sanitaire encore et cette semaine
et puis une question sur le champagne
après ce qu'on a vu en russie autour de
l'appellation champagne
encore une question sur la protection
judiciaire des mineurs une question sur
les appelle une question sur la filière
bois beaucoup de sujets comme chaque
semaine qui vont être multipliées en
séance mais donc quand même on va
revenir largement sur ce qui s'est passé
autour de ce référendum puisque
effectivement c'est la toute première
question de feeling baky qui va
commencer sur ce sujet qu'est ce que je
peux vous dire d'autre sur le
le programme on peut aussi noter cette
question sur les cyber-attaques qui sera
posée par le groupe rdp irm une question
sur l'accession au masters qui sera
posée par l ai l air une question aussi
sur la fia aluminium qui sera imposant
toute fin de séance des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement ou encore
sur la prévention des risques d
inondation on le voit donc beaucoup de
sujets aujourd'hui avec également
effectivement des questions sur sur le
variant delta qui inquiète toujours
mais donc on va commencer par ce bras de
fer entre le gouvernement et le sénat
alors que voilà la cloche a retenti que
c'est parti pour cette séance d'une
séance a été distribué il n'ya pas
d'observations reçu à cette heure y'en a
t'il en séance
je n'en bois points ne procès verbal est
donc adoptée sous les réserves d'usagé
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues je ne peux pas commencer cette
séance sans avoir une double pensée de
pensée pour notre collègue patrick boré
qui nous a quittés dans cette ville
dimanche et que nous accompagnerons
demain certain nombre d'entre vous vers
ce qui pour lui le conduit dans sa
hauteur spirituelle vers l'éternité
patrick boré c'était un homme que nous
connaissions depuis peu de temps pour
certains d'entre nous mais dont
l'élévation personnel politique et
spirituelle forcé l'admiration et le
respect de chacune et de chacun
je sais que vous aurez demain une pensée
pour lui et quelques semaines nous les
rendrons hommage dans cet hémicycle
j'ai une pensée bien sûr pour sa famille
pour sa chère ville de la ciotat pour
son département des bouches du rhône et
pour tout ce qu'il a gardée je voudrais
aussi vous dire la tristesse que nous
avons pris ce matin et je m'adresse à
l'ensemble des collègues et
particulièrement groupe du rassemblement
démocratique social et européen avec la
disparition de celui qui la préside et
pierre laffitte pierre laffitte celui
qui créa sophia antipolis
celui qui fut le directeur de l'école
des mines un grand scientifique patron
du brgm et qui apporta ici cette
dimension scientifique si particulière
et un engagement politique dans la
tradition du parti radical je voulais
avoir aussi une pensée pour celui qui
animait nos débats ici certains s'en
souviennent encore et de senna n'oublie
pas ce qui est porté par le groupe qu'il
a présidée
four merci
notre ordre du jour appelle des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
notre séance et comme à l'accoutumée
retransmis sur public sénat notre site
internet chacun sera attentif au respect
du sein déjà des autres et à celui du
temps de parole et premier orateur et le
questeur philippe bas pour le groupe
l'est républicain
vous avez la parole
monsieur le premier ministre en matière
constitutionnelle en vertu de l'article
89 de la constitution l'assemblée
nationale et le sénat sont à égalité de
droit par deux fois le sénat a voté
l'inscription de la préservation de
l'environnement
à l'article 1er de la constitution
certes il a affirmé librement ses
propres convictions différentes des
vôtres et de celle de l'assemblée
mais si vous reprochez au sénat de ne
pas avoir recopié le texte de
l'assemblée nationale nous pourrions
tout aussi bien vous reprocher de ne pas
avoir repris notre propre texte
c'était à vous premiers ministres de
rechercher l'accord
or non seulement vous ne l'avez pas fait
mais vous avez de surcroît laissé votre
porte parole nous insulter car c'est
bien nous insulter que de nous traiter
de climato sceptiques quand on mesure
comme nous la gravité des effets du
réchauffement climatique pour l'humanité
je vous demande donc monsieur le premier
ministre de manifester votre respect
pour la représentation nationale en
retirant les propos indignes qui ont été
tenus en votre nom
[Applaudissements]
la parole
c'est au garder chaud
ministre de la justice monsieur eric
dupond-moretti vous avez la parole si
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs monsieur le questeur bas
comme vous l'indiquez le sénat a fait le
choix hier d'enterrer et je le crains
définitivement comme vous l'indiquez le
sénat a fait le choix d'entrer je le
crains définitivement le projet de loi
constitutionnelle relatif à la
préservation de l'environnement
issu des travaux de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat la proposition
la proposition phare de la convention
citoyenne sur le climat auquel le
président de la république s'était
engagé avec un objectif clair très clair
soumettre aux français un texte
ambitieux visant à ériger la protection
de l'environnement et la lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique en principe
constitutionnel est imposé aux pouvoirs
publics une véritable obligation
d'action en la matière cet objectif
monsieur le questeur aurait dû tous nous
réunir
la position du sénat que je respecte
bien sûr absolument persiste perd 6 à
proposer en réalité un texte qui n'a
strictement aucun effet juridique vous
préférez la charte de 2004 et vous ne
vous rendez pas compte qu'elle a un peu
vieilli
le premier ministre a indiqué hier
devant l'assemblée nationale que le
gouvernement prenait acte de cette fin
de non recevoir
la différence que vous le vouliez ou non
entre nos positions est ainsi désormais
tout à fait clair l'urgence climatique
ne présente pas à vos yeux le même degré
d'importance qu'aux nôtres
les français et en particulier les plus
jeunes pourront se rendre compte à quel
point sur ce sujet fondamental nos
approches sont opposés nul tout comme
monsieur le questeur nul artifices
politiciens il ira il y a et il y aura
désormais toujours une grave occasion
manquée cieux questeur
[Applaudissements]
oh non monsieur le premier ministre
c'est vous et vous seuls qui avait
interrompu le processus de la révision
constitutionnelle n'est pas
climato-sceptiques quiconque refuse de
cautionner votre politique écologique
vous n'avez pas le monopole de
l'écologie le gaullisme dont vous
essayez de vous réclamer monsieur le
premier ministre
ce n'est pas la pensée unique et nous ne
sommes pas une chambre d'enregistrement
nous n'avons le droit de préférer le
développement durable à l'écologie de la
décroissance
ce débat de fond et dignes d'être portés
devant les français et croyez moi il le
sera si vous ne le fait pas maintenant
dès 2022 à notre initiative à l'occasion
de l'élection présidentielle merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la parole est à notre collègue olivier
henno pour le groupe de l'union
centriste
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de la santé
monsieur le ministre
alors qu'une quatrième vague épidémique
menace une inquiétude de monde parmi les
professionnels de santé
y aura-t-il cet été une pénurie de
soignants dans les hôpitaux la crise de
lakovic 19 a été éreintante pour nos
soignants nombreux on était surmené
ils ont besoin de souffler l'été
s'annonce donc particulièrement
difficile
il suffit de lire dans la presse
régionale pour s'en convaincre tous les
voyants sont au rouge dans la nouvelle
république
on apprend que dans la vienne la pénurie
d'infirmiers qui s'annonce est très
inquiétante dans la dépêche on peut lire
que la clinique de montauban est en
quête de nouveaux infirmiers qu'elle
peine à recruter le télégramme révèle
qu'il manque des infirmiers des aides
soignants dans les établissements de
santé et médico-sociaux de bretagne dans
la région des hautes france la voix du
nord indiqué hier encore dans un article
que la filière médicale du groupe
randstad recherche 531 professionnels de
santé d'ici la fin de l'année
la situation devient si catastrophique
que dans certains établissements on
envisage les fermetures estivales de
service qui relève de la permanence ou
de la continuité des soins comme les
urgences les soins critiques où la
psychiatrie c'est impensable
alors monsieur le ministre ma question
est simple que comptez vous faire pour
remédier à ce risque de carence de
ressources humaines dans les hôpitaux
je vous remercie
répondre à la parole et à madame la
ministre déléguée en charge de
l'autonomie madame bourguignon où ils
avaient la parole merci monsieur le
président monsieur le sénateur olivier
henno depuis plus d'un an nos soignants
c'est vrai sont soumis à une rude
épreuve et dans la crainte aussi d'un
rebond épidémique ça nous oblige
évidemment à prendre collectivement la
mesure du moment
d'une manière générale hors période de
crise chaque période estivale est
victime de ce problème de désaffection
parfois du personnel cette période fait
toujours l'objet d'attentions
particulières par les ars et cela
suppose que nous adaptions finalement
finement la réponse la plus adaptée au
territoire bien sûr selon la diversité
des zones géographiques et estivale qui
évolue drastiquement par endroits
chaque établissement de santé et tenues
d'anticiper l'organisation et la gestion
des services au regard de la situation
épidémique actuel de l'évolution
attendue de la démographie en fonction
des impératifs de service comme des
droits sociaux je pense notamment aux
congés du personnel
vous comprendrez que cette prévision a
fait l'objet d'une attention
particulière cette année au regard de la
forte mobilisation des soignants et de
la nécessité qu'ils avaient de se
reposer le contexte avec l'émergence du
variant delta à la fois plus contagieux
plus mortelle nous oblige à redoubler de
précaution pour ne laisser aucun
territoire sans offre adaptée par
ailleurs face à la crise sanitaire un
certain nombre de décisions de
reprogrammation de soins ont dû être
prises
les services sanitaires sont pleinement
mobilisées pour assurer ses
reprogrammation permettre à tout à
chacun en particulier aux personnes les
plus vulnérables en raison de leur état
santé d'un suivi particulier
les ars veille tout particulièrement à
la bonne organisation de cette période
sensible avec un principe de solidarité
territoriale ainsi dans votre région
mais sur le sénateur le chru de lille
aide les établissements alentour comme
celui de tourcoing par exemple
lorsqu'ils rencontrent des difficultés
pour assurer la continuité et la
permanence des soins
nous sommes donc pleinement mobilisés
sachez le notamment en cette période de
crise monsieur hainaut
mais si madame la ministre pour votre
réponse mais je ne vous cache pas que
j'attendais autre chose vous aborder la
question sous l'angle structurelles vous
aborder la question en justifiant votre
politique
mais ma question concerne et l'urgence
et je pense que vous minimiser le
problème est que vous n'avez pas répondu
ou que très partiellement à la question
qui était posée jour merci merci la
parole est maintenant un autre collègue
pierre laurent pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et des écologistes
il avait la parole merci monsieur le
président madame la milice mes chers
collègues
obéissant à une instruction
interministérielle les services
d'archivés ont dû consacrer des moyens
humains considérables à déclassifier des
documents secret défense que la loi de
2008 rendait pourtant communicables de
plein droit après un délai de 50 ans
l'accès aux archives publiques secret
défense a été ainsi massivement bloqué
pendant des mois
le conseil d'état vient d'annuler cette
instruction ministérielle qui la
considérait tout simplement illégal près
d'un million de documents historiques
ont reçu un tampon de déclassification
sans aucune raison valable
nous laisserons d'ailleurs pour les
générations futures toutes ces pièces
ont tâché de ce temps pau le sénat qui
avait participé activement à
l'élaboration de la loi de 2008 parce
qu'elle donnait aux documents d'archivés
statut patrimonial garant de leur
fonction historique vous demande
pourquoi avez vous laisser faire une
telle absurdité
pourquoi une prétendue raison d'état l'a
emporté
pour interdire à des historiens de
publier des sources qu'il compte qu'il
consultait jusque-là librement mais en
dépit de ce désaveu cinglant animé par
cette même volonté de censure
votre gouvernement propose maintenant
par l'article 19 de la loi sur le
terrorisme et le renseignement de
restreindre cette fois sans limite de
délai l'accès aux archives
allez vous écoutez le conseil d'état qui
dans son arrêt rendu
après notre discussion législative
considère que la loi de 2008 suffit
allez vous renoncer à cet article 19 et
donner un feu vert à sa réécriture
encore possible lors de la cmp du
vendredi 9 juillet quand vous répondent
la parole est à mme amélie délégué en
charge de la citoyenneté madame dardenne
chappard vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur tient laurent je tiens tout
d'abord à affirmer que le gouvernement
n'ait pas moins attaché que les chacun
d'entre nous à ce que les historiens
puissent accéder dans les meilleures
conditions possibles aux archives
publiques leur travail est bien sûr
indispensable et plus largement
d'ailleurs le conseil constitutionnel a
reconnu que le droit d'accéder aux
archives publiques était une composante
importante du contrôle démocratique par
les citoyen de l'action de
l'administration
pour preuve de cet attachement le
gouvernement a souhaité mettre fin à
certains désordres qui avait été
engendrée par l'obligation faite aux
administrations de déclassifier les
documents classifiés avant toute
communication et ce quel que soit leur
âge
cette démarche c'était une démarche
d'ouverture qui rejoint la position
finalement prise tout récemment par le
conseil d'état le droit d'accès de tout
citoyen aux archives publiques n'est
cependant pas un droit absolu la
nécessité d'un contrôle démocratique sur
le travail de l'administration doit être
conciliée avec d'autres impératifs de
valeur constitutionnelle également il
est bien évident en effet que la
divulgation précoce de certains
documents pourraient être de nature à
compromettre les intérêts fondamentaux
de la nation et doit donc être empêché
le rapporteur public au conseil d'état
l'a relevé dans les termes les plus
nettes
cette conciliation il appartient au
parlement de la réaliser
qui voudrait en effet que puissent être
révélées au public y compris à des
personnes ou des puissances mal
intentionnés à notre rencontre
les plans des infrastructures de la
dissuasion ou les modes d'emploi nos
armements les plus sensibles
il n'a jamais été question il n'a jamais
été question de fermer les archives des
services de renseignement l'article 19
du projet de loi relatif aux actes de
terrorisme et aux renseignements aura
pour seul effet d'empêcher la
communication des archives quand
celle-ci dévoilerait des méthodes
d'action encore en usage dans nos
services au détriment de la sécurité des
agents et de l'efficacité de leur action
mais oui c'est ça parfaitement le texte
issu du sénat sont par conséquent
réalisé une conciliation équilibrée
entre les différents intérêts en jeu et
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'a également
estimé le conseil d'état au terme d'un
examen approfondi lors de son examen du
projet de loi je vous remercie monsieur
le président pierre laurent madame la
ministre
s'il vous plaît vous le verrez dans
laurent madame la ministre vous venez de
nous répéter l'argumentation défendu
depuis le début par le gouvernement qui
vient justement de tomber avec l'arrêt
du conseil d'état qui a clairement
rappelé que le sol principe qui vaille
et la communication de plein droit des
archives à près de 50 ans sauf dans des
cas très précis que vous refuser
d'inscrire dans l'article 19 alors que
cinq groupes du sénat ont proposé dans
la discussion parlementaire le même
amendement de réécriture de l'article 19
si vous vous entêtez et si vous laissez
faire
la cmp dans ces conditions la parole
publique sera durablement entacher sur
une question majeure pour l'accès au
patrimoine de tous les français
la parole est à notre collègue thani
mohamed soilihi pour le gros du
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendant vous avez
la parole la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
plus un jour ne se passe sans qu'une
cyber-attaque ne surviennent comme l'a
alerté le directeur général de l'anssi
il y a quelques semaines la menace croit
plus grand monde n'est à l'abri
certaines sont moins médiatisés mais
peuvent entraîner des conséquences
redoutées c'est le cas du centre
hospitalier de mayotte qui connaît
chaque mois près de 400 tentative un
chiffre vertigineux dans un contexte de
pandémie
d'autres sont massives comme celles
toujours en cours contre l'entreprise
kaseya et qui paralysent 1500 de ses
entreprises clientes dans 12 pays
des cyber attaques sont toujours plus
sophistiqués les cyber rançonneurs se
professionnalise et demain dans un monde
davantage interconnecter les vecteurs de
cyberattaques ne cesseront de se
multiplier mais le plus inquiétant est
le profil des trois principales victimes
de rançon j ciel en france à savoir les
collectivités territoriales les
établissements de santé et les
entreprises du secteur industriel notre
paix et notre pme déjà bien éprouvé par
la crise économique
développe de nouvelles vulnérabilités
avec le télétravail ou encore le recours
massif aux services cloud
la cyberattaque en cours le montre elles
sont directement touchées lorsque son
cheese et des fournisseurs de services
informatiques
en février le président de la république
a présenté une stratégie nationale de
source eau avec un plan d'un milliard
d'euros pour aider à renforcer les
systèmes de protection informatique et
soutenir la filière française de la
cybersécurité la semaine dernière encore
il
annoncé un plan innovation santé 2030
dans lequel 650 millions d'euros seront
dédiés à la santé numérique dont
justement la cybersécurité monsieur le
ministre
où en sommes nous dans le développement
de notre stratégie d'accélération au
cyber sécurité et notamment dans
l'accompagnement de nos tpe et pme
face à la menace cyber on vous répondra
par an les taux souverains terres d'état
en charge de la transition du mérite et
des communications électroniques
fonctionnent ministre merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur merci 2
de mettre l'accent sur ce sujet qui dans
le fond et une nouvelle pandémie qui
touche vous l'avez dit absolument tout
le monde est parmi les plus fragiles les
plus touchés il ya les hôpitaux les
collectivités territoriales les tpe pme
et l'ensemble des citoyens pour donner
une idée de l'importance de l'impact
le centre hospitalier de dax qui est
donc été touchée je crois tout début de
l'année se remet à peine aujourd'hui à
fonctionner normalement
c'est dire particulièrement dans un
moment de crise sanitaire à quel point
la question de la cybersécurité est
absolument essentiel c'est pour cela que
le président de la république a souhaité
en faire une cause nationale
il y a quelques mois qui repose sur
plusieurs éléments
d'abord c'est renforcer notre niveau de
préparation dans l'ensemble des domaines
et des secteurs avec notamment vous
l'avez évoqué un plan particulier pour
les hôpitaux et au sein de ce plan en
particulier pour les hôpitaux
un plan particulier pour les hôpitaux
outre mer parce que l'on comprend que si
un centre hospitalier outre-mer
devraient être touchés on ne pourrait
plus détourner le fut notamment de
passion qu vite ça c'est le premier
élément
nous avons également c'est le
renforcement des moyens à la fois de la
coopération judiciaire sous l'égide
d'eric dupond moretti avec les autres
pays on a vu certains succès
dernièrement l'appréhension de du groupe
cybercriminels mtep en ukraine il ya
quelques jours mais également des moyens
de l'ansea la troisième réponse est
évidemment la réponse technologique
c'est pour cela que
l'état et l'ensemble de l'écosystème
investira plusieurs centaines de
millions d'euros dans les mois qui
viennent pour apporter une réponse
technologique car c'est aussi un domaine
de compétence française dans lequel les
français peuvent à la fois aider à ce
que nous soyons mieux préparés mais
également développer nos emplois merci
je vais lever maintenant la parole notre
collègue bernard jomier pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicaine
que vaut la parole merci monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres dans
cet hémicycle la semaine dernière notre
collègue catherine procaccia vous
interroger sur les mesures concrètes que
vous comptiez prendre face à la
quatrième vague de virus elle n'a pas
obtenu de réponse précise
depuis la seule annonce concrète et le
projet d' obligation vaccinale pour les
soignants qui pour légitime qu'ils
puissent être n'aura qu'une influence
marginale sur l'évolution de cette
quatrième vague
donc je réitère la question quelles
actions concrètes comptez-vous prendre
et je vous invite à vous référer
notamment proposition de notre mission
d'information pauvres pour protéger les
français de cette quatrième vague
je remercie pour vous répondre la parole
et la milice délégué en charge de
l'autonomie madame brigitte bourguignon
nommé la parole maintenant même si
monsieur le sénateur monsieur le
président monsieur le sénateur bernard
amis et je pense que vous partagez comme
moi cette préoccupation majeure qui est
de protéger les français durant cette
crise sanitaire et personne ne peut se
renvoyer la balle à ce sujet le contexte
actuel vous le connaissez le taux
d'incidence du virus remonte
progressivement il atteint aujourd'hui
24 pour cent mille cette augmentation
s'accentue soul influence du variant
delta 60% plus contagieux que le variant
alpha dominant et qui entraîne bien sûr
une flambée épidémique
la solution est donc à portée de main
pour autant le nombre de rendez-vous de
vaccination est resté stable pendant
plusieurs semaines alors que nous
disposons des doses et des dates
nous restons et nous notons ces jours-ci
depuis nos appels une légère
augmentation à la ddt dollars
notamment pour les rendez vous pour une
injection face aux variants dalta delta
il est désormais impératif que cette
augmentation de la demande se confirme
et s'amplifie
il faut aller se faire vacciner sans
aucune hésitation je le rappelle 1700
centres de vaccination sont
opérationnels partout en france
nous nous mobilisons partout en france
et pendant tout l'été à travers des
dispositifs d'aller vers important des
centres de vaccination éphémère sur les
lieux culturels comme au festival
d'avignon printemps de bourges des levac
six bus en nouvelles aquitaine pour les
saisonniers des centres de vaccination
mobile notamment dans les landes qui
vont à la rencontre des publics éloignés
des opérations spéciales en
ile-de-france dans la canopée des halles
par exemple est à la défense
par ailleurs je rappelle que pour
faciliter la vaccination une souplesse a
été introduite dans le délai entre les
deux injections je vous le rappelle est
ensuite la vaccination le seul sénateur
c'est la clé c'est la clé quoi qu'on en
dise pour maintenir notre retour à une
vie normale nous protéger protéger ceux
qui nous sont chers et ceux dont on
prend soin j'appelle donc tous les
français à se faire vacciner
notamment pendant cette période estivale
monsieur j'ai oublié
merci madame la ministre je note que par
rapport à la semaine dernière
il y a dénoncé la volonté d'une
politique de la l'éleveur en termes de
vaccination et nous pouvons saluer au
moins ce point là même si nous ne la
voyons pas encore concrètement
mais pour le reste la stratégie tester
tracé isolé nous avions dû abandonné du
fait d'un niveau trop élevé de
l'épidémie peut à nouveau être menées de
façon efficace et avec la remontée des
chaînes de contamination nous avions
bien pris note que cette et
théoriquement le cas depuis le 1er
juillet mais l'effectivité de cette
mesure n'est pas complète
elle est pourtant importante le
dépistage est aussi important pour
pouvoir limiter l'ampleur de la vague et
qu'on va arriver à la rentrée scolaire
il faudra être prêt comme le nous
démontre l'étude de l' agence nationale
maladies infectieuses que nous avons
commandé à mettre en place un dépistage
itératif dans les écoles pour les
enfants de moins de 12 ans il faut
pendant l'été vacciner les adolescents
et donc mettre en place un dispositif
spécifique pour les vacciner pendant
leurs vacances et les autres il faudra
aller vacciner comme le propose aussi le
président du comité de stratégie
vaccinale les adolescents dans les
collèges et les lycées à la rentrée
ce que le ministre de l'éducation
nationale refuse pour le moment je vous
invite donc bien sûr intensifier la
vaccination et dans toutes ses
dimensions y compris obligatoire si
nécessaire mais à ne pas négliger les
autres mesures qui permettront de
transformer la vague en vaguelettes jour
merci merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue jean yves
roux pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen avait la
parole
si monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues ma question
concerne notre politique de prévention
des inondations et les moyens financiers
pour la mettre en oeuvre
mes chers collègues la compétence
jemmapes y confier aux intercommunalités
depuis sept ans a permis d'apprécier
finement les risques courus par les
populations et les investissements
indispensables pour les protéger elle
s'appuie sur une ressource optionnel
pouvant aller jusqu'à 40 euros par
habitant aujourd'hui chacun sur ses
bains c'est les discussions autour du
projet de loi climat et résilience leur
rappeler que cette ressource n'est pas à
la hauteur des enjeux
les territoires de faible densité avec
des linéaires de cours de deux cours
d'eau capricieux tire la sonnette
d'alarmé
ils ne parviendront pas à assurer la
sécurité de la population face aux
risques d'inondations
voici mes chers collègues un exemple
celui de la communauté de communes un
peu province vers d'or les besoins
d'entretien des digues pour 2021 se
monte à 9 cents cinquante mille euros
soit le plafond des ressources possibles
les investissements à venir sont
estimées à dix millions d'euros a minima
avec un reste à charge écrasant combien
de communautés de communes les alpes on
croise dans notre pays
combien de communes aucune jabron
l'urgence honduras combien de cristaux
rangueil et il y en a beaucoup et chers
collègues la prévention des inondations
nécessite une solidarité nationale
pleine et entière
monsieur le ministre non les ressources
j'aime api ne sont pas sous utilisées
elles sont mal réparties et sont
profondément inégalitaire faisant peser
une position importante sur des
populations qui n'ont aucune assurance
que leur sécurité soit garantie
non monsieur ministre et ressources
j'aime api ne sont pas suffisantes à la
part à la hauteur des enjeux climatiques
monsieur le ministre les régions ne se
précipiteront pas pour reprendre la
gestion de la compétence et chers
collègues
hélas le réchauffement climatique et la
violence des intempéries futur
on n'attendra pas que toutes nos
collectivités des moyens de prévenir les
risques mortels d'innovation pour faire
des ravages
aussi monsieur le ministre que pouvez
vous proposer rapidement pour prévenir
avec les collectivités concernées
ces risques mortifère dans nos
territoires je vous remercie pour vous
répondre la parole et au secrétaire
d'état en charge de la ruralité que joël
giraud la parole monsieur merci monsieur
le président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur jean yves
rousse et bien comme vous l'avez rappelé
la loi map tam a créé une co une taxe
qui est destiné à financer la gema pile
gestion des milieux aquatiques et de
prévention des inondations
je me rappelle d'ailleurs que
l'amendement qui a institué cette taxe
avait été d'ailleurs porté par le sénat
après plusieurs rapports sénatoriaux et
un travail de fond qui avait été conduit
avec le gouvernement les principes sur
lesquels repose la taxe n'ont pas changé
depuis 2014 il reste pleinement valable
le premier principe une recette locale
pour une problématique locale la gestion
d'innovation n'a pas la même intensité
partout où elles n'existent pas
d'ailleurs partout et en tout état de
cause le gouvernement un vaste attaché à
ce que le financement de la compétence
relève bien des décideurs locaux et pas
des décideurs nationaux second principe
une taxe qu'ils soient facultatives car
tous les opci n'ont pas les mêmes
besoins en matière de levée de cette
taxe pas dans les mêmes proportions du
moins et en doute tous les territoires
ne sont pas organisés de la même manière
il ya des opci qui gère directement la
compétence d'autres qu'ils le font au
travers de syndicats de rivières voire
même plusieurs syndicats qu'ils peuvent
aussi financé à des contributions
budgétaires et le troisième principe
c'est un plafond vous l'avais dit à 40
euros par habitant et par an qui permet
de limiter la pression fiscale et
j'observe que les capacités de la taxe
jemmapes ils ne sont d'ailleurs pas
intégralement mobilisés
en 2000 26 ans 3 à l'intercommunalité
percevez la taxe pour 204 milliards
d'euros soit moins de 6 euros par
habitant par exemple dans les alpes de
haute provence 5 intercommunalités ce 8e
à essorer la taxe la com com alpe
florence verdon aperçu 638 1000 euros
avec un maximum qui aurait pu être de
940 la com com lui revend son durant
jabron peu après levé 48 mille euros
pour oak versus 239 1000 euros de
maximum et celle du système et des
bûches et à 149 mille pour près de 1
million 2 alors je suis conscient pour
autant monsieur le sénateur il existe
des manuels mais certes des marges de
manoeuvre mais que l'enjeu est
particulièrement spécifique à la
montagne et j'observe que sur les
intercommunalités des départements alpes
elle la plupart ont institué cette taxe
je m'engage donc à regarder avec avec
vous et de très près les conditions et
les marges de manoeuvres actuelles qui
sont probants si elles sont bien adaptés
ou au contraire s'il s'agit de
dévolution qui serait opportune la
parole est à notre collègue ronan dantec
pour le groupe écologie solidarité est
terrible
merci monsieur le président ma question
va donc s'adresser à monsieur le
ministre des transports le 1er juillet
dernier le conseil d'état a donné neuf
mois seulement neuf mois à l'état
français pour définir de nouvelles
mesures de politiques publiques lui
permettant de tenir ses engagements
climatiques et nous venons par ailleurs
d'examiner ici la loi climat et
résilience vaguement très vaguement
inspiré des travaux de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat
concernant cette loi l'étude d'impact et
l'avis du haut conseil sur le climat
sont sans appel elle ne permet pas
d'atteindre les objectifs internationaux
sur lesquels la france est engagée dans
le cadre de l'accord de paris les
projections nous amène au mieux vers 1 -
3 - 35 % d'émissions de gaz à effet
serre d'ici 2030
loin de notre objectif de 2015 qui était
de - 40 % et plus encore
tu nouvel objectif fixé par le conseil
européen de -55% toujours d'ici 2030
question simple monsieur le ministre le
gouvernement devra maintenant faire au
parlement de nouvelles propositions pour
que la france tienne ses engagements
comment concrètement comptez-vous donc
procéder et pour éviter une réponse un
peu flou ça peut arriver
deux questions complémentaires plus
précise allez-vous dans le cadre de la
navette parlementaire et de la
commission mixte paritaire chercher à
garder les mesures les plus ambitieuses
qu'a proposé le sénat comme la dotation
climat pour les collectivités où la tva
à 5,5 sur les billets de train ce qui
renforcerait déjà ses lois et comme cela
ne pourra néanmoins suffire une autre
interrogation assez binaire préférez
vous utilisez la loi actuelle ou au
contraire mettre d'ores et déjà en
chantier dans les neuf mois une vraie
loi climat pour répondre à l'urgence
climatique
pour vous répondre la parole et au
ministre délégué en charge des
transports monsieur djebbari il avait la
parole merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur dantec
plusieurs éléments d'abord vous dire
qu'il est devenu fréquent que les
juridictions se prononce sur les actions
engagées par les gouvernements ça a été
par exemple le cas en allemagne où le
juge constitutionnel a censuré la loi
pour leurs lois pour insuffisances en
terme d'action climatique ce n'est pas
le cas du conseil d'état qui nous fait
injonction de mettre en oeuvre
complètement les mesures qui sont d'ores
et déjà engagés dans le plan de relance
et notamment les mesures qui sont
inscrits et au débat dans le projet de
loi climat et résilience vous savez dans
l'ordonnancé 30% 30 milliards qui sont
consacrés à notre action en faveur du
climat
avec d'ores et déjà et depuis 2010 et 9
des résultats sur l'industrie et le
bâtiment notamment s'agissant des
transports pour vous répondre plus
précisément les faits parlent pour eux
mêmes nous avons ré engagé depuis 2010
est plus de 75 milliards d'euros
d'investissements pour le système
ferroviaire
s'agissant des véhicules individuels qui
comme vous le savez compte pour 50% des
émissions transports
nous soutenons une des plus une des
transformations les plus rapides de
l'industrie automobile avec un plan
massif de développement des bornes avec
le soutien les constructeurs avec des
offres en tout cas des aides inédite
pour les consommateurs nous avons l'an
passé par rapport à l'année précédente
baisser le niveau d'émission de 15% et
ses mouvements vous savez va encore
s'accélérer avec les annonces comprise
notamment les constructeurs français
donc monsieur sénateurs nous serons au
rendez vous de cette transformation
nous serons au rendez vous de cette
révolution dans les transports et dans
l'énergie d'ailleurs aussi et nous
serons au rendez-vous des exigences
accrues de la commission que présentera
la commission européenne toutes
prochaines semaines
monsieur dantec monsieur le ministre le
conseil d'état vous demande d'en faire
plus vous nous répondez avec ce que vous
faites déjà ça ne colle pas donc si vous
manquez d'idées moi je vous propose la
lecture de la vraie loi qui m'a proposé
par le groupe écologiste qui dit comment
on pourrait faire moins 55 % en 2030
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue franck
menonville pour le groupe les
indépendants république et territoires
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
le redémarrage de l'économie mondiale
fait opérer une pression sur les
matières premières dont nous sommes
souvent dépendants entraînant ainsi des
difficultés d'approvisionnement pour
nombre d'entreprises
nous avons pourtant au coeur de nos
territoires une matière première de
qualité et en quantité
le bois malgré cela cette filière est
confrontée à de graves difficultés
d'approvisionnement elles aussi faut-il
le rappeler la filière bois la forêt
française est la quatrième surfaces
boisées de l'union européenne notre
filière bois représente quatre cent
quarante mille emplois soixante mille
entreprises et 60 milliards d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires or la demande
mondiale grandissante pour nos essences
et plus particulièrement nos chaînes et
l'absence de régulation de nos
exportations entraîne de lourdes
conséquences sur nos territoires en
effet aux jauges en effet actuellement
donc à chaîne sur trois récolté par en
chine sans transformation ni valeur
ajoutée sur le territoire force est de
constater que les scieries sont
contraintes de fonctionner en sous
régime
elles sont appelées à chômer et
fonctionne aujourd'hui à 60 % de leur
capacité de production
certaines régions comme le grand est
sont particulièrement concernés du fait
de la proximité des ports belges face à
ce phénomène
de nombreux pays réagissent afin de
protéger leurs filières je pense
notamment aux états unis al arish à la
russie qui ont déjà mis en place des
mesures de protection
pendant ce temps qu'un pendant que la
chine importe nos bois elle protège et
investi dans ces forêts pour l'avenir
même si la labellisation union
européenne a porté ses fruits dans la
forêt publique ce n'est à ce jour plus
suffisant monsieur le ministre il en est
donc urgent d'agir
si aucune mesure de régulation des
prises c'est toute la filière qui seront
impactées que comptez vous faire pour
préserver et mieux valoriser nos
ressources et ainsi mieux garantir
l'approvisionnement de la filière
si rien n'est fait des entreprises vont
disparaître pour nous répondre
la parole est tonique de l'agriculture
monsieur julien de normandie vous avez
la parole monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur franck milon ville
je vous remercie de pointer du doigt ce
sujet très compliqué qui est un vrai
sujet d'inquiétude pour l'ensemble de
l'activité forestière dans notre pays du
fait de la tension sur les marchés des
matières premières
qu'est ce que nous voyons arriver des
traders qui vient de spéculer sur les
offres de vente de bois particulièrement
les grumes de chêne mais aussi dans
d'autres essences forestières et qui
viennent se faisant capter la ressource
forestière et empêcher nos propres suri
sur nos propres territoires de pouvoir
les transformer alors c'est un sujet
qu'on connaît depuis longtemps mais qui
aujourd'hui prend des proportions
considérables et est une vraie source
d'inquiétude face à ça qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire
on a réuni à plusieurs reprises
évidemment la filière pour mettre en
place des dispositifs il y à des
dispositifs comme le label eu que vous
l'avez dit monsieur le sénateur mais le
label lieu aujourd'hui ne concerne que
le chêne et que dans les ventes
publiques l'eau nf le fais et je note
que plusieurs vendeurs privé aujourd'hui
rentrer dans ce dispositif
le deuxième élément très important c'est
la contractualisation
il faut plus de contractualisation mais
ça va prendre du temps la
contractualisation
donc elle est nécessaire mais elle ne
sera pas suffisante à court terme
le troisième élément c'est de porter le
sujet au niveau européen comme vous
l'avez dit d'autres puissances
forestières ont pris des mesures il nous
faut les porter au niveau européen c'est
ce que je fais en tant que ministre de
l'agriculture et de l'alimentation
et puis le quatrième élément il vous
l'avez adoptés le sénat l'a adopté
c'est de mettre en place des certificats
de qualification pour que seules les
personnes bénéficiant de ces certificats
ne puisse répondre aux appels d'offres
souvenez vous vous l'aviez fait il fut
un temps dans le cadre de la loi macron
dans le btp et c'est exactement la même
logique que vous avez adopté mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs sur ce sujet il
nous faudra peut-être aller encore plus
loin
on aura des débats sur les mesures
fiscales par exemple mais en tout cas
soyez sûrs d'une chose monsieur le
sénateur c'est un vrai sujet de
préoccupation que nous prenons à bras le
corps avec les filières parce que notre
bois français il doit bénéficier à notre
forêt française
si la parole est à notre collègue
jacqueline eustache brinio pour le
groupe l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président monsieur
ministre un récent rapport de
l'inspection générale de la justice
dresse un bilan catastrophique de la
situation dans les structures d'accueil
pour jeunes mineurs ce rapport concerne
toutes les formes de structures
d'accueil pour mineurs foyer centre
éducatif fermé publics ou associatifs
on apprend dans ce rapport étayé de
nombreux exemples que la protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse est en procès
par atis mme religieux que nous disent
les auteurs que des repas confessionnels
sont proposés aux mineurs sans
autorisation ni demande qu'un protocole
ramadan est rédigée par les éducateurs
en totale contradiction avec les règles
de la pjj et de la fonction publique que
les éducateurs parfois agents publics
s'auto attribue le rôle de conseiller
spirituel que certains de ceux qui sont
chargés d'éduquer refuse de serrer la
main de leurs collègues féminines que
des éducateurs font la morale aux jeunes
car leur comportement et non conforme
aux préceptes religieux
les inspecteurs généraux ont découvert
également qui n'est pas inhabituel que
des candidats présentant des casiers
judiciaires chargés ou signalé parle
pour suspicion de radicalisation se
présente au concours ou pour occuper des
fonctions contractuels auprès des
mineurs
monsieur le ministre la pjj connaît de
grandes difficultés et ce sont vos
services d'inspection qui le constate et
l'écrivent le principe de laïcité
s'impose à tout agent de l'état a
fortiori lorsqu'il a un rôle d'éducateur
pourquoi monsieur le ministre est lui
resté silencieux sur les conclusions de
ce rapport
qu'avez vous fait depuis la publication
de ce rapport pensez vous que ces
pratiques communautaristes aide les
jeunes confiée à la pj à se réinsérer
dans notre société
pensez vous qu'il faille mettre un terme
aux dérives communautaristes de la pjj
et si oui comment comptez vous vous y
prendre pour répondre la parole qu'aux
gardes
oui de la justice monsieur eric dupond
moretti
monsieur monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs
d'abord c'est nous qui avons demandé ce
rapport parce que nous avions un certain
nombre d'éléments qui nous permettait de
craindre les exemples absolument
désastreux qu'à juste titre vous
stigmatisez et que je stigmatise en même
temps que vous avant que ce rapport
d'aujourd'hui il a été rendu en janvier
j'ai pris une première note en décembre
pour dire et pour rappeler à quel point
la laïcité était absolument essentiel
particulièrement à la pjj pour des
raisons qu'il n'est pas besoin de
développer davantage
j'ai pris ensuite une deuxième note du
11 décembre pour redire à quel point il
était extrêmement important et pour
rappeler les règles
ce rapport est arrivée nous avons tiré
un certain nombre de conclusions
immédiate
d'abord décider des procédures
disciplinaires qui sont en cours et qui
connaîtront bien évidemment si cela est
mérité
les sanctions qui conviennent ensuite
nous avons fait un certain nombre de
choses
j'ai élaboré un plan d'action puisque
c'est le thème de votre question destiné
à la pjj qui prévoit bien sûr la
réaffirmation des principes de laïcité
sur le site que j'ai créé intranet
j'ai répondu à toutes les questions que
pouvait se poser les éducateurs face à
des revendications do mineur enfin nous
avons clarifié et nous voulons clarifier
le cadre juridique pour une meilleure
appropriation par les personnels des
règles applicables
je vous informe que le conseil d'état va
être saisie de cela et bien évidemment
nous souhaitons que ces chantiers
aboutisse le plus rapidement possible je
suis à votre disposition pour vous
communiquer tous les éléments qui sont à
ma disposition je veux tout de même dire
ici que ce que l'on a pu lire dans la
presse est exagérée par rapport aux
conclusions même de l'inspection
générale de la justice qui montre une
fois encore son indépendance mais qui
nuance un peu
ce que vous nous présentez comme une
véritable catastrophe
il y a des choses qui ne vont pas je
prendrai toutes les mesures qui
s'imposent en ce compris les mesures
disciplinaires et sachez madame que le
gouvernement est particulièrement
attentif aux questions de laïcité
particulièrement quand elle concerne mes
enfants au brio de chemini j'aurais aimé
en temps dans vos propos que vous allez
demander à la pjj
comment il pouvait faire en sorte
d'apprendre aux jeunes à aimer la france
parce que quand on a des jeunes en
charge
on leur apprend à aimer la france a
participé à un destin commun à aimer nos
valeurs et amis nos principes
parce que manifestement dans mes propos
je vous ai signalé qu'un certain nombre
d'entre eux les emmenait vers le chemin
du communautarisme et malheureusement je
pense que les jeunes méritent mieux que
ça alors effectivement vous m'avez donné
des réponses très technique mais
remédier sur les problèmes de fond je
pense que c'est de votre soirée ut comme
la responsabilité du gouvernement
[Applaudissements]
redonner la parole maintenant notre
collègue jean-michel en garde pour le
groupe socialiste et écologiste et
républicaine
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre le groupe socialistes
écologistes et républicains n'a eu de
cesse ces derniers mois d'interpeller le
gouvernement sur l'inadéquation de son
action avec les engagements
internationaux de réduction de 40% des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre d'ici
objectif désormais est fixé à 55% dans
le cadre du pacte vert pour l'europe est
inscrit dans la loi climat par
amendement du sénat lors de l'examen
cette loi climat alors que le haut
conseil sur le climat en pointé le
manque d'ambition le gouvernement
reconnaissait lui même que ce texte ne
permettait pas à lui seul de respecter
ses engagements
mais nous étions invités à analyser la
politique gouvernementale dans son
ensemble pour en comprendre la réelle
portée
or c'est précisément comme l'a rappelé
ronan dantec tout à l'heure ce que vient
de faire le conseil d'état dans une
décision historique sans précédent
le 1er juillet il a ainsi fixé un
ultimatum à l'état français d'agir dans
les neuf mois en se joignant monsieur le
premier ministre à prendre toutes les
mesures utiles permettant d'infléchir la
courbe des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre l'heure est à l'urgence
alors monsieur le ministre pouvez vous
nous confirmer la volonté du
gouvernement de maintenir dans la loi
climat
l'inscription de la réduction de 50% qui
résulte du pacte vert européen et
quelles mesures complémentaires
envisagez-vous pour au delà de
l'injonction du conseil d'état atteindre
c'est le nouvel objectif
pour vos réponses la parole est aux
ministres fériés chargé des transports
monsieur djebbari merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur je vais redire ce
que j'ai dit précédemment nous serons au
rendez-vous des exigences que nous
sommes en train de bâtir notamment au
niveau européen avec un renforcement
encore des mesures que nous prenons pour
réduire les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre pour améliorer la qualité de l'air
et vous le savez d'ores et déjà et
depuis 2010 9
nous produisons des résultats dans les
secteurs du bâtiment dans le secteur de
l'industrie et nous avons engagé des
très grandes transformations notamment
dans le secteur des transports et
d'énergie
les transformations qui ont mobilisé des
moyens importants je le disais 75
milliards d'euros sur dix ans dans le
secteur ferroviaire en mettant un terme
au sous-investissement chronique que
nous avions vécu jusqu'à présent en
relançant des politiques écologiques qui
n'était plus financé et qui ne
trouvaient plus leur public je pense
notamment au fret ferroviaire aux trains
de nuit au petit in ferroviaire et nous
avons engagé cette très grande
transformation technologique et
industriel autour de la filière
automobile
c'est comme vous le savez représentent
50% les émissions transports les
émissions transports représentant l 30%
des émissions à l'échelle nationale nous
serons au rendez vous nous avons bâti
les dispositifs de soutien pour que
l'ensemble des français aient accès
notamment un des véhicules et des coûts
abordables je le redis ici quand vous
cumulez par exemple le bonus électrique
les prime à la conversion les aides des
collectivités pour un véhicule
électrique neuf vous pouvez avoir
jusqu'à dix 19000 euros de prime une
structure ont un marché de l'occasion
nous déployons très massivement des
bornes de recharge et vous avez pu
apprécier que l'ensemble du tissu
industriel les constructeurs français et
européens ont pris les engagements qui
permettent d'accélérer très
substantiellement ce qui était il ya
encore quelques temps les courbes de
référence en cloud seront au rendez vous
monsieur le sénateur
sur le seul ministre la communication ne
doit pas se substituer à l'action
l'heure du bilan du quinquennat en
matière environnementale approche et la
transition écologique s'avère elle être
celle du renoncement écologique voire de
l'illusion écologique renoncement au
respect des échéances renoncement dans
la nécessité de changer nos logiciels
pour produire consommer travailler
différemment renoncement à cette belle
ambition du développement durable qui
conjugue les performances éthique et les
justices économique environnemental et
social
sachez que comme dans les collectivités
que nous administrons est bien ce que
vous n'avez pas c'est nous serons nous
au rendez vous pour le faire dans un an
donner la parole de trois collègues
florence lassarade pour le groupe l'est
républicain
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues selon santé publique
france alors que 92 % des médecins
généralistes sont vaccinés contre la
copie
seuls 57% des professionnels les ehpad
et 64 % des professionnels des
établissements de santé ont reçu au
moins une dose de vaccin contre la copie
de la couverture vaccinale des soignants
reste insuffisante et on a déjà pu
observer une reprise épidémique dans
certains ehpad en italie la vaccination
a été rendue obligatoire pour les
soignants au mois de mai ils sont
désormais 98 % avoir reçu une première
dose
le royaume uni a annoncé qu'il allait
rendre obligatoire la vaccination
complète contre le coronavirus pour
toutes les personnes travaillant dans
les maisons de retraite
madame la ministre l'obligation
vaccinale en france ne serait en aucun
cas une nouveauté la première fois
qu'une loi imposer l'obligation
vaccinale c'était en 1902 pour protéger
la population contre la variole
cette mesure a disparu avec l'extension
avec l'extinction de la maladie agnès
buzyn arrondies aux vaccins obligatoires
pour les nourrissons
ce qui a contribué à renforcer la
confiance des parents dans les vaccins
quatre axes 1 sont déjà obligatoires
pour les soignants l'hépatite b la
diphtérie le tétanos et la polio dans un
arrêt rendu le 8 avril 2021
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
soulignent que l'obligation vaccinale
nécessaire dans une société démocratique
lorsqu'il ya un impératif de santé
publique alors que la menace d'une
quatrième vague épidémique liée à la
propagation du variant delta voire
peut-être le variant epsilon se profile
madame la ministre
allez-vous rapidement proposé de rendre
la vaccination contre le coc vide
obligatoire pour les professionnels de
santé
on vous répond ma parole et canam inc
kelly en charge de l'animal un bon
million merci monsieur le président
madame la sénatrice florence lassarade à
ce jour un lit de réanimation est encore
occupée par un patient sur cinq par un
patient atteint de covin si cette part
continue de baisser
fruit des efforts consentis par les
français on en conviendra
l'émergence de nouveaux variants plus
contagieux potentiellement plus mortels
aussi nous oblige à redoubler de
vigilance vous avez raison dans ce
contexte la protection des plus
vulnérables quel que soit le statut
d'ailleurs est vitale et c'est une
priorité leurs soignants et leurs
accompagnants doivent se faire vacciner
nous sommes où nous en sommes convaincus
c'est un impératif qu'il me semble
nécessaire de rappeler pourtant la
couverture vaccinale des soignants est
plus faible que celle de la population
générale
alors que 80 1% des résidentes
d'établissement d'ehpad que vous citez
sont vaccinés et que nous avons choisi
sciemment de commencer par eux
d'ailleurs cette campagne vaccinale
seulement 60 % des professionnels de
santé
même s'il ya eu un rebond ce mois ci ne
sont toujours pas vaccinées sont
vaccinés c'est une forte progression
mais c'est nettement insuffisant vous
avez raison il existe de très grandes
disparités de plus d'un établissement à
l'autre
je lance de nouveau à travers vous un
appel solennel aux soignants et
notamment en ehpad à se faire vacciner
c'est un sujet de responsabilité qui
nous oblige tous la situation pourrait
nous contraindre à une obligation
vaccinale par voie légale des soignants
c'est une mesure dans laquelle sur
laquelle nous avons souhaité lancer une
large concertation car cette obligation
vaccinale ne se fera pas sans consensus
à ce titre je recevrai cet après midi
avec olivier véran les ordres
professionnels les fédérations
hospitalières et les ehpad
le premier ministre recevra l'ensemble
des présidents des groupes
parlementaires et des associations
d'élus jeudi à ce sujet pour autant je
crois utile de le rappeler la
vaccination obligatoire et vous l'avez
dit n'est pas nouvelle puisqu'elle
concerne déjà les soignants c'est
d'ailleurs une mesure de bon sens quatre
vaccins sont obligatoires il s'agit de
la diphtérie du tétanos de la polio de
l'hépatite b et donc nous pardon six
autres sont très forts sont fortement
recommandés la rougeole la rubéole la
varicelle la coqueluche et la grippe qui
n'est pas obligatoire non plus je vous à
12 je vous invite donc de nouveau relayé
cet appel à vacciner comme comme vous
venez de le faire je suppose la
concertation c'est bien l'action la
décision c'est quand même beaucoup mieux
et c'est impératif maintenant madame la
ministre
[Musique]
la parole est à notre collègue nathalie
goulet pour le groupe de l'union
centriste
le président mesdames messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question concerne le verset du cheval le
haras du pin cher évidemment au coeur
des normands des ornais et de notre
président gérard larcher
je veux d'abord remercier les ministres
gouro et de normandie d'avoir engagé par
lettre rectificative au projet de loi
3ds
la dissolution de l'établissement public
administratif du haras du pin qui ne
donnait pas satisfaction ils ont ainsi
répondu à l'appel du député jérôme nury
du président du conseil départemental de
l'ordre christophe de balorre et du
président de la région hervé morin les
collectivités départements et régions
ainsi souhaité reprendre en main la mise
en place d'un projet ambitieux
touristique et sportif ce texte est
discret sur les délais d'exécution
compte tenu de l'importance de ce
dossier pour le département de l'ordre
mais aussi pour l'institut français du
cheval et de l'équitation pour
l'institut national de la recherche pour
l'agriculture l'alimentation
l'environnement
il est important que le gouvernement
s'engage sur un calendrier précis
monsieur le ministre pouvez vous vous
engagez sur la dissolution effective de
l'établissement public au plus tard dans
les six mois de la promulgation de la
loi
avec un transfert concomitant des biens
immobiliers l état et des biens
mobiliers au département de l'orne je
vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole était aux ministres de
l'agriculture
monsieur julien de normandie merci
beaucoup monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice nathalie goulet ma réponse est
très claire
1 le gouvernement soutient pleinement le
projet et je vous remercie pour vos mots
de ce projet il doit se faire le plus
rapidement possible la date précise sera
d'ailleurs discuté dans le cadre des
amendements que vous aurez dans le cadre
du projet de loi 3ds et 4 ce calendrier
doit être compatible avec lui l'ensemble
des échéances à court et moyen terme que
nous avons et qui implique le beau
territoire normand et qui implique
également l'institut française du cheval
et qui implique également notre pays
dans sa renommée à l'international je
pense à des sujets que vous suivez avec
précision comme les championnats
mondiaux qui doivent arriver dans les
prochaines années
donc ma réponse elle est très claire ça
doit se faire et ça doit se faire le
plus rapidement possible j'en veux pour
preuve d'ailleurs que cette lettre
rectificative au projet de loi que
j'évoquais elle a été présentée par le
gouvernement en conseil des ministres
pour s'assurer au cas particulier de la
robustesse de la mise au sein du projet
de loi de cette disposition pour
qu'elles ne puissent pas ensuite être
d'y joindre ou autre c'est la preuve la
plus précise la plus forte quand soutien
du gouvernement sur ce projet et
pourquoi un tel soutien pour deux
raisons d'abord je voudrais le souligner
les élus locaux les collectivités
locales de ce beau département de l'orne
de cette région normandie soutiennent
depuis des années ce projet et ils ont
raison et je voudrais leur rendre
hommage
le deuxième élément c'est que le haras
du pin pour bien le connaître à titre
personnel également c'est un joyau c'est
un joyau qui donne depuis maintenant
plusieurs siècles quitte un lieu
d'exception
qui est un lieu d' expertise qui a connu
de grands vétérinaire monsieur le
président qui a connu des heures de
gloire et il nous faut absolument
absolument le faire perdurer et donc ce
projet est un très beau projet et nous
le soutiendrons totalement je vous
remercie madame goulet oui monsieur mais
j'ai rappelé votre engagement je vous ai
d'ailleurs remercier ainsi que
jacqueline gourault mais une une grande
confiance n'exclut pas une petite
méfiance c'est la raison pour laquelle
je leur posais la question parce que
vous avez cités les événements
internationaux qu'elle est qu'est
l'espace et dont les championnats du
monde donc tout retard sera extrêmement
préjudiciable à la réalisation
vous savez que faire et défaire c'est
travailler puisque nous avions eu les
mêmes arguments au moment de la création
d'établissement public administratif qui
a pas fonctionné
donc c'est vraiment très important et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nouveau en
confiance mais néanmoins il faudra
assurer cette mise en place dans un
délai qui soit pas celui du
refroidissement du felica non merci
la parole est à notre collègue antoine
le fait pour le groupe les régulateurs
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres
ma question à laquelle j'ai aussi
l'ensemble des sénateurs des
départements de l'appellation champagne
s'adresse au ministre de l'europe et des
affaires étrangères monsieur le ministre
d'aucuns se souviendront de la
condamnation de 1993 par la cour d'appel
de paris d'une grande maison de couture
française rendu coupable d'avoir nommé
l'un de ses parfums champagne
trente ans plus tard la question de la
protection de l'intégrité de cette
appellation est de retour dans
l'actualité
une loi signée le 2 juillet dernier par
le président de la fédération de russie
interdit désormais aux bouteilles
importées à l'ip de l'étranger de faire
figurer la mention traduits en russe du
mot champagne et en laisse luchazes
l'usagé exclusif aux producteurs russes
tout en reléguant l'original français au
rang de vin mousseux
un comble pour cette appellation
d'origine contrôlée dont la
reconnaissance de la paternité
champenoise a pris plusieurs siècles le
comité interprofessionnel du vin de
champagne annoncé suspendre ses
exportations vers la russie tant que ce
conflit commercial n'aura pas trouvé de
résolution satisfaisante
en s'arrogeant un patrimoine vinicole
dont la france a l'exclusivité titulaire
la russie compte revient allègrement aux
conventions du commerce international
exerce une pratique concurrentiel
déloyal à l'égard de son troisième
partenaire économique
pas plus que les producteurs français
n'auraient la prétention de s'arroger la
paternité de la production de borce de
vodka ou de caviar de saumon russe
les producteurs russes sont tenus de
respecter la protection du patrimoine
étranger et ne peuvent contrevenir aux
règles élémentaires du droit du commerce
sans encourir les sanctions légalement
applicables voici ma question quelles
mesures le gouvernement tente il prendre
à l'encontre de la russie dans le but de
garantir l'exclusivité française de
l'appellation champagne et le restaurer
la pleine application du droit du
commerce on nous répond on à part les
communistes de l'europe des affaires
étrangères monsieur ces messieurs les
sénateurs le fait vous avez raison dans
le diagnostic et dans les inquiétudes
que peut entraîner cette nouvelle loi
russe qui est très récente qui date de
vendredi dernier que sur laquelle nous
sommes avec julien de normandie et
franck riester extrêmement mobilisés à
la fois pour l'analyser parce qu'il faut
d'abord l'analyse et très concrètement
et pour l'enrayer parce qu'on voit bien
toutes les conséquences que cela peut
avoir sur les professionnels des vins et
spiritueux et sera en particulier sur
nos exportations en champagne substituer
le momu ce hameau champagne même si
c'est en cyrillique
ce n'est pas très convenable avoue avoir
avant le
alors face à cela face à cela
d'ailleurs je remarque que ce n'est pas
la première initiative protectionnistes
dans ce domaine vineet vitivinicole qui
se produit à partir de la rue si on a
déjà eu l'occasion au cours des derniers
mois de porter nos préoccupations au
niveau européen pour le respect des
indications géographiques et pour le
respect des indications mission protéger
à face à cela nous avons engagé des
discussions avec les professionnels nous
allons prendre le connais vos contacts
nécessaires et les rencontres
nécessaires avec les autorités russes
dans les jours qui viennent et nous
allons aussi agir au niveau européen
pour faire en sorte que les intérêts nos
producteurs et nos indications
géographiques soient protégés et nous
avons déjà prévu de porter le sujet au
niveau européen la semaine prochaine
lors d'une réunion sur les obstacles à
l'accès aux marchés pour nos entreprises
dans un premier temps on va parler et si
la devanture
il n'avait pas de solution rapide nous
n'hésiterons pas si c'était nécessaire
et s'il cette loi est contraire aux
règles de l omc en tirer toutes les
conséquences et donc à faire appel au
sein de cette juridiction pour faire
valoir le respect de nos droits et de
nos indications géographiques
merci monsieur lefebvre mais je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre pour cet
engagement et cette réponse le
gouvernement avait récemment affirmé son
engagement aux côtés des viticulteurs
français à deux occasions lors de la
menace d'augmentation des taxes sur les
vins français par l'administration
trompe ainsi qu'au vent de la discorde
entre airbus et boeing
sachez donc maintenir ce soutien il est
primordial en effet que ce fuseau que ce
sujet pardon ne soit pas considérée
comme une tempête dans un verre d'eau
mais bien comme un ouragan dans une
flûte de champagne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
me donner la parole à notre collègue
viviane artigalas pour le groupe
socialiste écologistes et républicains
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre
quatre millions de pièces justificatives
en attente des allocataires en
difficulté et des agents excédés vous
n'êtes pas sans savoir que la mise en
oeuvre de la réforme des aides
personnalisées au logement connaît de
telles difficultés techniques que les
personnels des caisses d'allocations
familiales ont fait grève le 29 juin
dernier
nous avons tous été alertés par leurs
syndicats sur les nombreux
dysfonctionnements techniques qu'ils
rencontrent avec leurs logiciels de
traitement qui s'ajoutent à une
situation déjà fortement dégradées en
raison de l'obsolescence leurs systèmes
informatiques
ces difficultés en train de des retards
de traitement des délais allongés pour
le versement des prestations familiales
qui représentent souvent pour les
allocataires une part importante de
leurs revenus
elles sont particulièrement prégnante
dans le contexte de crise actuel et
confirme surtout le fait que la réforme
des apl était dès son origine
une mesure inadéquate mal préparés car
sans étude d'impact prévue pour janvier
2020 elle a déjà été reportée de six
mois face à la difficulté de sa file
mise en oeuvre par les caf la pandémie
de pandémie de kobe 19 a finalement de
porter ce décalage à un an sans que les
moyens nécessaires étaient déployés pour
autant madame la ministre
quand allez vous accorder les moyens
techniques et humains nécessaires à
l'application de cette réforme
et quelle compensation prévoyez-vous
pour les allocataires sortie trop vite
du système pour vous répondre en charge
du logement
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice à viviane artigalas la réforme
du calcul des apl en temps réel est une
réforme indispensable de modernisation
de notre protection sociale parce
qu'elle vise à rendre ce système plus
juste et plus réactif
elle a effectivement été reportée elle a
été mise en oeuvre opérationnelle mans
au 1er janvier dernier et les deux
calculs celui d'avril et celui de
juillet
ont pu avoir lieu dans des conditions
globalement satisfaisante pour les
allocataires
d'abord les ressources sont préremplies
désormais ce qui veut dire que les
allocataires n'ont plus besoin de
transférer des ressources d'une base
fiscale à la base des caf et que ça
améliorera le taux de non recours ça
permettra de lutter contre le non
recours ensuite je partage le constat et
je voudrais saluer les agents des caf et
de la cnaf sur les difficultés
opérationnelles
il y a eu des bugs il y a eu des
difficultés opérationnelles ils ont
finalement été peu préjudiciable aux
allocataires grâce à un investissement
une mobilisation et un engagement très
fort des agents que je salue nous les
accompagnons dans la modernisation des
systèmes d'information dans les montées
en la montée en charge des compétences
un plan d'action est prévue sous l'égide
bien sûr du directeur général de la cnaf
enfin sur le bilan général de la réforme
nous pourrons publier des chiffres dans
le courant du mois de juillet à la fois
sur l'évolution de la dépense apl qui
est en phase avec nos prévisions
initiales et à la fois sur l'impact sur
les allocataires nous avons fait très
attention à préserver les étudiants et
les alternants que ce soit les jeunes en
contrat d'apprentissage ou les personnes
en contrat de professionnalisation est
d'ailleurs dans la réforme les
ressources des étudiants sont maintenant
neutraliser ce qui permet une situation
plus favorable pour les étudiants qui
travaillent donc croyez bien que nous
suivons attentivement le pilotage de
cette réforme
au plan opérationnel avec la cnaf au
quotidien cette réforme permet d'ajuster
au plus près la protection sociale à la
situation des assurés
madame ministre comme d'habitude tout va
bien mais si les moyens étaient alors à
hauteur des enjeux il n'y aurait pas
autant d' alerte à ce sujet les caf dans
le béni doivent bénéficier des moyens
adéquats pour assurer leurs missions
auprès des usagers
c'est la question de l'accès aux droits
des allocataires que vous nous que nous
vous rappelons ici il n'est pas normal
que certaines pertes deux d'un seul coup
192 euros d'allocations pour passer à 14
euros
puis plus rien du jour au lendemain sans
compensation et il y en a il n'est pas
normal que les auteurs soient si
nombreux alors que la réforme était
censée permettre un traitement des
dossiers en temps réel il devient usant
de constater que ce gouvernement ne
reconnaît jamais ses erreurs et que sans
ce toujours nos concitoyens les plus
précaires qui en payent les conséquences
parole et un autre collègue alexandra
burke souvent type sont le groupe est
républicain
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur
sandy une licence de droit quatre sages
de contrat de travail de mandats
associatifs vingt candidatures en master
0 admission laurent 49 demande en master
à ce jour zéro admission c'est à dire
zéro chance de réussir à concrétiser ses
ambitions ce n'est ma lame la ministre
qu'un aperçu de la détresse dont nous
sommes témoins depuis des années encore
plus ces jours ci après les cours à
distance et la détresse psychologique
bien s'ajouter les chèques incompris
combien d'étudiants sont tiraillés entre
l'angoissé de ne pouvoir construire un
avenir et la colère et la frustration
aussi de voir que leurs efforts étaient
vains
beaucoup trop et toujours plus ça vous
le saviez déjà en 2017 vous aviez même
promis de répondre aux conséquences du
baby boom de 2000 en assurant que tout
le monde trouverait sa place
et bien non tout le monde n'a pas trouvé
sa place si le processus de sélection ne
fait pas débat
la république ne peut tolérer un système
nébuleux qui explique à cette jeunesse
qu'elle n'est pas à la hauteur
vous avez su ni anticiper ni gérer
principalement pour ce qui est du nombre
insuffisant de places en droit à nice
sont quinze mille candidatures pour 1200
places vous annoncer la création de 34
mille places supplémentaires
c'est bien aucune ne concerne la
quatrième année que direz vous à ses
étudiants plein d'espoir lorsqu'il se
retrouveront face aux portes fermées du
masters cessons cette hypocrisie c'est
un gâchis monumental que de stopper net
les landes étudiants qui ne demande qu'à
poursuivre leurs études
le droit au masters ne s'envisage plus
sans le dépôt d'un recours plus 129% de
saisine en un an dans le meilleur des
cas elles sont obligées d'accepter
l'unique chance offerte comme patrick
étudiant en psychologie à nice contraint
d'accepter un master en audiovisuel à
angers soyez la ministre qui l'attendent
agissez
pour vous répondre
[Applaudissements]
l'april vidalies d'enseignement
supérieur de la recherche et
d'innovation relève la ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le président
permettez moi tout d'abord au nom de
l'ensm de l'ensemble dû gouvernement et
en mon nom propre de m'associer à
l'hommage que vous avez rendu aux
sénateurs la chute vous savez je suis
particulièrement attaché à la technopole
de sophia antipolis qu'il avait imaginé
et ses divisions étaient réellement
visionnaire vous m'interrogez mama
sénatrice sur les conditions d'accès au
master vous savez en 2016 la sélection à
l'entrée du masters a été consacré il me
semble d'ailleurs que le sénat était
évidemment pour cette proposition et en
même temps et de manière assez
intéressante a aussi été créé un droit à
l'accompagnement à la poursuite d'études
en master c'est à dire que dans le même
temps ce que dit la loi c'est qu'il ya
une sélection à l'entrée du masters mais
qu'on doit accompagner les étudiants qui
le souhaitent pour qu' on puisse
faciliter leur accès c'est exactement ce
que nous faisons même la sénatrice et
contrairement à ce que vous venez de
dire eh bien il y aura plus de 4000
places créées en master et là aussi je
crois que c'est très important de
rappeler qu'une fois de plus c'est une
prise en charge humaine qui est fait
c'est à dire que ce sont les recteurs
qui en lien avec les établissements et
en lien avec les résultats des étudiants
madame la sénatrice et évidemment c'est
bien normal de le faire et bien regarde
ce qui peut être proposé comme le
gouvernement s'y était engagé et bien il
y aura des places qui seront créés pour
les masters les plus sélectifs et puis
vous parlez des masters de drogba vous
ne l'ignorez pas je pense
qu'effectivement les formations de droit
malgré la réforme de 2016 du master
continuer à accueillir des étudiants est
main sans aucune sélection et faisait
intervenir cette sélection entre le m1
et le m2 laissant ainsi les étudiants en
plein milieu d'un cursus en plein milieu
d'un cycle
eh bien ça aussi c'est ce gouvernement
qui aura mis fin je remercie
je suis au fond cheap labour je suis
petit puisque vous jouez faire prendre
la parole quand j'avais pensé naïvement
qu'on vous donnant le sujet de ma
question j'aurais des réponses claires
pour rassurer nos étudiants une seule
réponse donc s'imposer créant des places
en master j'ai bien écouté vos annoncera
serait bien bien sûr attentive pour que
ces annonces se concrétise vous avez dit
ce qui peut être proposé aux étudiants
espérons que cette possibilité
deviennent vraiment quelque chose de
concret parce que ils sont aussi dans
l'hémicycle aujourd'hui et je crois
qu'ils ont vraiment besoin de votre
soutien plein et entier la parole
dominique vien pour le groupe de l'union
centriste
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre
tout d'abord j'associe à ma question mes
collègues stéphane demilly et valérie
létard la filière aluminium en france
est en plein développement
ce matériau est un produit vertueux car
il se récite à l'infini mais seulement
50% de l'aluminium primaire est produit
en france
or l'union européenne entend créer un
mécanisme d'ajustement carbone aux
frontières qu'elle devrait présenter
dans les prochains jours
cette nouvelle taxe si elle devrait
permettre d'aider nos filières acier
ciment dont la matière première est
produite en france viendrait
sérieusement peser sur la compétitivité
de notre filière aluminium qui comme je
les dis précédemment importe 50 % de sa
matière première très concrètement cette
taxe viendrait augmenter le coût des
produits fabriqués en france et comme
elle ne s'appliquerait pas sur les
produits transformés
il serait plus économique d'importer le
produit fini directement de cris la
chine
madame la ministre est bien donc toute
la filière de l'aluminium français qui
risque d'être sacrifiés au nom d'une
taxe qui n'aurait même pas les effets
désirés sur le climat puisque la
production se délocaliserait tout
simplement en dehors de l'union
européenne à l'abri de nos règles
environnementales
que comptez-vous donc faire pour
sauvegarder cette filière d'avenir et
protéger la souveraineté industrielle
française pour vous répondre la parole
et qu'avant
annie espagne et rue najimy liste de
délits en charge de l'industrie voilà
mme la ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice vais rien vous le savez le
président de la république par des
positions ambitieuses au niveau de la
commission et du conseil européens en
matière industrielle et le mécanisme
d'ajustement carbone aux frontières
il rentre dans ses positions ambitieuses
il doit permettre aux états membres de
protéger contre la concurrence déloyale
de pays qui ont du fort contenu carbone
et qui produisent et importe massivement
en europe nos industries qui produisent
en europe et qui respecte des
contraintes environnementales fortes et
c'est particulièrement le cas de
l'aluminium de l'acier et du ciment ou
l'avait mentionné et des entreprises
comme aluminium dunkerque par exemple
denny fisher est très fortement de ce
mécanisme alors vous avez région l'enjeu
c'est de mettre au point un mécanisme
qui permette à l'intérieur de l'union
européenne de faire payer aux
marchandises qui ont été fabriqués avec
des émissions carbone qui n'ont été payé
par personne de payer cet impact sur
l'environnement
et il faut être attentif à ce que les
exportations qui sont réalisées avec ces
matériaux de base acier aluminium ciment
eux mêmes puissent rester compétitifs à
l'exportation
si tout le travail que nous sommes en
train de mener avec la commission
européenne où effectivement nous portons
cette volonté de rompre avec le cercle
vicieux qui nous a conduits à augmenter
nos émissions carbone par augmenter
notre empreinte carbone du fait
d'importations massives tout en
réduisant notre industrie en france donc
c'est ce cercle vicieux contre lequel
nous luttons et évidemment nous serons
attentifs à la situation de l'aluminium
nous sommes d'ailleurs en discussion
avec eux pour qu'elles puissent
bénéficier également de ce mécanisme
je rappelle que le mécanisme
d'ajustement carbone aux frontières
créer des recettes pour l'union
européenne qui peuvent être utilement
employés par exemple pour accompagner
les filières exportatrices c'est un des
sujets sur lequel nous travaillons
je vous remercie
mais rien merci madame 1 min zhu parler
effectivement de dung quât qui est
justement une création d'aluminium
primaire mais moi je vous parle de tout
ce qui est secondaire cd r d production
de canettes de machines de pièces et
c'est donc j'entends bien que vous
entendez travailler avec eux aujourd'hui
ils attendent toujours de rencontrer
thierry breton pour justement parler de
ce 6 de ce cas particulier qu'est
l'aluminium
effectivement le ciment et l'acier n'ont
pas du tout le même souci est donc il
est nécessaire de prendre l'aluminium de
façon différenciée par rapport à cette
taxe
et donc j'ai bien entendu que vous les
aviez entendu et nous comptons sur vous
merci monsieur le premier ministre
faisait messieurs les ministres merci
notre prochaine séance de questions
d'actualité aura lieu le mercredi 21
juillet à 15 heures
je vais maintenant suspende la séance et
sera reprise à 16h40 pour l'examen du
projet de loi relatif à la
différenciation la décentralisation la
déconcentration important diverses
mesures de simplification de l'action
publique locale
la séance est suspendue
[Musique]
voilà pour cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement que vous
avez pu suivre en intégralité et en
direct sur public sénat place maintenant
aux des bribes de cette séance de
questions d'actualité et on va tout de
suite allé en tribune de presse de
l'hémicycle du sénat retrouver quentin
quel mec qui a suivi avec attention
cette séance
et quand on peut dire que ça a commencé
par de vives tensions entre la droite
sénatoriale et le gouvernement
exactement alex 1 dès le début de cette
séance la tension était palpable dans
l'hémicycle puisqu'on a vu que et bien
l'abandon de la révision
constitutionnelle et qui visait à
introduire dans l'article 1 la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique s'est
tout de suite invité dans les débats
pour rappel après deux lectures dans
chacune des deux chambres du parlement
députés et sénateurs n'arrivaient pas à
s'entendre sur une même écriture de
cette modification de l'article 1 les
sénateurs je le rappelle encore il ne
voulait pas du verbe garantir que
pourtant l'exécutif et et est la
majorité lrm voulait introduire dans
l'article 1 il disait qu'il fallait un
verbe d'action
les sénateurs avaient peur de ce verbe
est donc depuis hier et encore
aujourd'hui on l'a vu en sortie du
conseil des ministres
la majorité et l'exécutif ont blâmé la
responsabilité des sénateurs dans cette
impossibilité de trouver une même
écriture dans la révision
constitutionnelle et ça eh bien ça n'a
pas du tout plu aux sénateurs qu'ils ont
donc dix dès la première question dans
une question du lr fait l'iba écoutez un
extrait c'était à vous premiers
ministres de rechercher l'accord or non
seulement vous ne l'avez pas fait mais
vous avez de surcroît laissé votre porte
parole nous insulter
car c'est bien nous insulter que de nous
traiter de climato sceptiques quand on
mesure comme nous la gravité des effets
du réchauffement climatique pour
l'humanité je vous demande donc monsieur
le premier ministre de manifester votre
respect pour la représentation nationale
en retirant les propos indignes qui ont
été tenus en votre nom
ouais les plaimont était fort et même
philippe bas était longuement applaudi à
la fin de cette question les sénateurs
qui ont rappelé que le sénat et
l'assemblée nationale ont le même poids
en matière de révision constitutionnelle
je vous le rappelle il n'y a pas de deux
derniers mots pour l'assemblée nationale
sur ce type de texte
et d'ajouter que le sénat a bien réécrit
l'article rail n'ont pas rejeté l'idée
d'une révision constitutionnelle n'y
avait pas d'accord sur les mots choisis
et que c'est bien le gouvernement qui a
décidé d'arrêter la navette
parlementaire entre les deux chambres du
parlement
écoutez la réponse du garde des sceaux
tout à l'heure l'urgence climatique ne
présente pas à vos yeux le même degré
d'importance qu'aux nôtres les français
et en particulier les plus jeunes
pourront se rendre compte à quel point
sur ce sujet fondamental nos approches
sont opposés nul tout comme monsieur le
questeur nul artifices politiciens il
ira il y as et il y aura désormais
toujours une grave occasions manquées
voilà et donc on a vu cette tension
entre la droite ici au sénat et le
gouvernement
plus tard dans la séance à l'excès bien
ça nous vaut un peu chauffé sa question
de l'écologie entre la gauche sans les
écologistes et est également le groupe
socialiste sur l'action de l'écologie
donc mais sur le conseil d'état qui a
rendu un ultimatum la semaine dernière
au gouvernement
merci beaucoup quentin pour ce résumé de
cette séance noter qu il a aussi été
question de l'obligation vaccinale
puisque le gouvernement consulte
actuellement les élus les groupes
parlementaires sur une éventuelle
obligation de vaccination des soignants
pour éviter et bien une quatrième vague
de l'épidémie de coronavirus à cause du
vin rayon delta et donc la sénatrice et
républicains florence lassarade a
interrogé le gouvernement sur cette
obligation vaccinale
écoutez cet échange madame la ministre
l'obligation vaccinale en france ne
serait en aucun cas une nouveauté la
première fois qu'une loi imposer
l'obligation vaccinale c'était en 1902
pour protéger la population contre la
variole
cette mesure a disparu avec l'extension
avec l'extinction de la maladie agnès
buzyn a rendu aux vaccins obligatoires
pour les nourrissons
ce qui a contribué à renforcer la
confiance des parents dans les vaccins
quatre axes 1 sont déjà obligatoires
pour les soignants l'hépatite b la
diphtérie le tétanos la pole du haut
alors que la menace d'une quatrième
vague épidémique liées à la propagation
du variant delta voire peut-être le
variant epsilon se profile madame la
ministre
allez-vous rapidement proposé de rendre
la vaccination contre le coc vide
obligatoire pour les professionnels de
santé
je lance de nouveau à travers vous un
appel solennel aux soignants et
notamment en ehpad à se faire vacciner
c'est un sujet de responsabilité qui
nous oblige tous la situation pourrait
nous contraindre à une obligation
vaccinale par voie légale des soignants
c'est une mesure dans laquelle sur
laquelle nous avons souhaité lancer une
large concertation car cette obligation
vaccinale ne se fera pas sans consensus
à ce titre je recevrai cet après midi
avec olivier ferrand les ordres
professionnels les fédérations
hospitalières et les ehpad
le premier ministre recevra l'ensemble
des présidents des groupes
parlementaires et des associations
d'élus jeudi à ce sujet la concertation
c'est bien l'action la décision c'est
quand même beaucoup mieux et c'est
impératif maintenant madame la ministre
voilà pour cet échange autour de
l'obligation vaccinale on va maintenant
retrouver notre streamer politique jean
messier qui a commenté toute cette
séance de questions d'actualité sur sa
plateforme twitch avec sa communauté
alors jean tu me disais avant la séance
que et bien les membres de ta communauté
attendait justement des réponses autour
du rpt de l'échec du référendum sur le
climat promis par emmanuel macron du
coup ils ont été servir avec ses vives
tensions entre philippe bas eric
dupond-moretti absolument alès ça
commençait fort cette séance avec
philippe a superstar si je puis dire du
sénat 13 heures
sur ce sujet là philippe bas qui a
effectivement dit tout le mal qu'il
pensait de la position du gouvernement
il a même demandé des excuses
directement de la part du porte parole
du gouvernement sur sur ce sujet je te
cache pas que ici dans le cha sur twitch
il ya eu quand même pas mal de débats
d'incompréhension mais pourquoi est ce
que les sénateurs ont empêché l'adoption
de cette de ce référendum pourtant il
avait l'air pour philippe à part le
développement durable de la charge de
l'écologie montier à laquelle il se
réfère le démarque à elle finit pas ce
débat étymologique ce débat politique
sur développement durable et croissance
et c est un débat auxquel bah oui les
internautes aux raiders voulez
participer à l'occasion d'un référendum
il ya un sentiment de gâchis je te gâche
pas chez les internautes autour autour
de ce sujet c'est un peu une déception
j'ai pas de cachet et argent est ce que
les membres de ta communauté eux ont
tranché entre une vision de l'écologie
de développement durable peut-être plus
soucieuse de l'économie et et peut-être
une écologie que la droite sénatoriale
appel décroissante unkut je pense que la
plupart des internautes rejette cette
dichotomie entre deux entre deux modèles
les internautes sont plutôt et tu le
sais ils sont là ces jeunes ils sont
plutôt du côté d'une dune d'une écologie
bien pu bien plus radicale que ce que
proposait même le gouvernement donc
c'est vrai qu'on tende philippe a traité
le gouvernement de décroissante east de
quasiment deux dangereux pervers
ça en a fait rigoler plus d'un mais pour
autant voilà c'est un débat absolument
passionnant que encore une fois il
aurait bien voulu avoir de l'or cote de
leur point de vue c'est encore une heure
un engagement de la convention citoyenne
pour le climat qui n'aura pas été
respecté cette fois-ci certes pas la
responsabilité du gouvernement
mais la droite sénatoriale dont il
vraiment un goût amer qui restent merci
beaucoup
genre on va continuer à débriefer cette
séance de questions de l'actualité on va
aller en salle des conférences du sénat
où steve jourdain est avec alain richard
le sénateur du groupe r des pays la
république en marche au sénat oui à un
richard bonjour merci d'être avec nous
le gouvernement table actuellement très
forte sur le sénat il accuse d'avoir un
peu sa beauté le référendum sur le
climat qu'est ce que vous en pensez
qu'en pense qu'il ya eu un désaccord
politique sur un sujet qui a évidemment
une grande portée et que
le gouvernement peut manifester sa
déception et sa désapprobation
sans porter atteinte à la dignité du
c'est là que j'ai moi-même c'est
vraiment une situation une position un
peu à part sur ce sujet je n'ai pas
beaucoup plus de commentaires à faire
mais enfin je ne crois pas qu'on puisse
parler d'un incendie institutionnels
alain richard début d'un marathon de
deux semaines autour du projet doit
décentralisation ça va commencer dans
quelques minutes on entend beaucoup de
critiques certains pas un texte qui
manque d'ambition quelle est votre
position là dessus je pense que c'est
très discours facile et que quand on va
discuter en là pour longtemps effet six
mois ya beaucoup de questions concrètes
beaucoup propositions dans tous les sens
on va s'apercevoir que le terme
d'ambition de toute façon est un peu
creux et qu'il s'agit de proposer des
solutions
et moi j'étais frappé au moment de
certaines auditions d'experts ou une
association que la paix doit beaucoup de
tirades sur l'ambition mais que les
propositions concrètes n'affluent est
pas donc moi je constate que ce projet
de loi au contraire essaye de répondre
après beaucoup de concertation à des
questions ou des attentes concrètes
je vous prends ou trois exemples très
consciemment qu'est ce qui va changer
dans la ville et favoriser la
participation citoyenne en abaissant les
seuils pour provoquer des consultations
citoyennes dans les collectivités
on va vous permettre plus de coopération
pour la remise en l'état ou l'adaptation
du réseau routier
lorsqu'il reste nationale mais que la
région veut apporter sa contribution
dans un plan d'aménagement ou encore on
permet au département d'apporter un
soutien technique aux petites
collectivités qu'il va faire un plan
pour le logement bien il me semble que
ce sont des quantités de réponse comme
ce qu'on fait avec l' agence pour la
cohésion des territoires qui facilite et
transformation de centre-ville comme ce
qu'on fait
dans plein d'autres domaines du secteur
social on va prévoir une coopération
entre les agences de santé et les
collectivités pour qu'elles puissent
contribuer aussi aux équipements de
santé locaux donc c'est une loi pratique
soucieuse de réalisme et donc puisque
faire des proclamations en disant je
suis plus ambitieux jours mettons nous
au travail et je suis on aura les
solutions qui seront partagées en texte
ambitieux donc merci beaucoup monsieur
richard merci d'avoir répondu à mes
questions
merci beaucoup style est à noter que
dans dix minutes
16h40 vous pourrez suivre le début de
l'examen au sénat de ce projet loi de
décentralisation avec cette question
quelles compétences de l'état faut-il
transférées aux collectivités locales
on va retourner en salle des conférences
du sénat puisque steve jardin est avec
le patron du groupe l'est républicain au
sénat bruno retailleau
oui bruno retailleau bonjour merci
d'être avec nous on le disait le
gouvernement qui tape très fort sur le
sénat sur cette histoire de référendum
sur le climat vous êtes accusés d'être
des climato-sceptiques est ce que vous
êtes climato-sceptiques bruno retailleau
non non pas du tout mais est ce que ça
vous étonne parce que tout ça était
écrit d'avancé
en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est que la
convention citoyenne avait donné une
piteuse note à emmanuel macron justement
pour son action pour la dérégulation du
climat et lui finalement a fait un coup
de com en essayant de sortir de son
chapeau un référendum
il a jamais voulu faire un référendum
sur le sujet à quelques mois de la
présidentielle
ça a été une scénographie bien réglé et
justement pour être sûr que le sénat ne
pourrait pas approuvés il a choisi un
terme
le mot garantir que le conseil d'état
pâle sedar le conseil d'état l'avait
dénoncé tout simplement parce que c'est
le virus de la décroissance
tout simplement parce que mettre ce
terme là dans notre constitution à
l'article 1er ça ouvre à une
jurisprudence aux magistrats foisonnante
contradictoires qui aurait en réalité
entraver le développement des
entreprises etc
il n'a jamais été question de faire ce
référendum le sénat pour lui est un bouc
émissaire commode commode de ses
impuissances et quel est le bilan
finalement en matière d'environnement
des mails macron ces quatre ministres en
quatre ans croyez qu'on peut faire du
bon boulot c'est des condamnations en
veux tu en voilà
par la cour de justice européenne par le
conseil d'état et par d'autres plus
écologique emmanuel macron mais en tout
cas je peux vous dire que par exemple
dans le texte sur le climat on a fait
des propositions qui n'ont pas été
adoptés par exemple la tva à taux réduit
sur les trains sur les trains pour
inciter justement les françaises et les
français à prendre le train plus que
leur voiture refusé et je pourrais vous
en citer d'autres bien évidemment la
fête la fermeture de fessenheim
c'est quoi havas et des effets de des
gaz à effet de serre en plus beaucoup
plus bruno retailleau l'actualité c'est
évidemment cette actualité sanitaires et
la progression du variant delta jean
castex consulte actuellement les élus
pour savoir un peu quelle sera la
prochaine étape la vaccination
obligatoire vous dites oui pour les
soignants comme je les dis au mois de
décembre à emmanuel macron depuis le
mois de décembre
à l'époque il m'avait repris en disant
ah oui mais on n'a pas de recul les
vaccins intentions etc
bon ben voilà il faut le faire je pense
que c'est important quand on les
soignants ou pour d'autres
collaborations pour le personnel
soignant a parlé par d'autres catégories
de la population peut pas faire que cela
parce qu'il faut une autre stratégie la
stratégie du bouclier c'est à dire la
stratégie tracée séquence est vraiment
isolé justement j'ai une mesure à vous
soumettre xavier bertrand déclare ce
matin que le passé ni terre finalement à
l'entrée de certains de nos loisirs
comme
restant ce serait une bonne idée est ce
que vous êtes en faveur de cette mesure
vous moi je suis plutôt pour rendre
payant les tests pcr sauf sur
prescription médicale
c'est ce que le gouvernement pour faire
que c'est une échappatoire
finalement à la vaccination mais ça ne
suffit pas tout simplement parce que la
vaccination nous n'arriverons pas au
seuil de 80 ou 90% de la population
avant de longs mois d'interdire tests
etc mais aussi faut anticiper la rentrée
il faut que le gouvernement instaure une
obligation qu'il pourrait aussi
cofinancer avec les collectivités que
dans chaque classe primaire collège
lycée on est un capteur de co2 en
n'étant pas le pass sanitaires pour moi
ça peut avoir des inconvénients on
aurait gens pas la liberté pour les non
vaccinés je pense qu'en tout cas à
l'heure où je vous parle il faut
massifier la vaccination essayer
d'inciter bruno retailleau bureau
politique de votre parti xavier bertrand
déclare ce matin qu'il est candidat à la
présidentielle sans primaire quoi qu'il
arrive
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire est-ce que
quoi qu'il arrive recouvre cette
hypothèse où il pourrait finalement y
avoir deux candidats au premier tour de
la présidentielle j'espère que non parce
que si à cette division c'est
nécessairement que le premier tour
jouerait le rôle d'une primaire
j'espère que ça n'est pas ce qu'il
souhaite et ce serait l'élimination la
porte de sortie directe et on s'en
remettra fin donc je pense que il faut
essayer de le convaincre
je souhaite moyenne une primaire plus le
temps passe plus longtemps presse et la
perspective d'une vraie primaire peut
s'éloigner mais je pense que c'est
encore la compétition loyale franche qui
permet finalement de trouver un leader
et ensuite aux autres de composer une
vraie équipe de france si vous échouez
elle convoitera participer à cette
primaire est ce que vous bruno
retailleau vous dites aujourd'hui que
vous seriez prêt à rejoindre l'équipe de
xavier bertrand à vous mettre derrière
lui pour la présidentielle confier ans
seul candidat à droite pour la
présidentielle
à me rejoindre si je gagne une primaire
mais il y aura-t-il une vraie primaire
est suffisamment ouverte justement parce
que on parle beaucoup d'abstention
linverse le contraire de la tension
c'est le vote alors pourquoi est-ce
qu'on est opposés au vote des militants
et sympathisants pour créer un élan
c'est je pense capital dans une
démocratie on doit pas avoir peur du
vote
c'est l'important petite dernière
question que j'avais 4 ans est le
candidat le flux est déterminé
aujourd'hui ça on va vers cette
présidentielle c'est le candidat le 1er
déc laré pas le plus déterminé il est
sans doute déterminé il sut candidats
qui sont déterminés mais j'ai pu voir au
chant discret depuis quelques jours pas
mal de candidats qui m'ont dit à
déterminer vous êtes déterminé on verra
là trimestre merci beaucoup merci
d'avoir répondu à mes questions
merci beaucoup civ avec cette réaction
bruno retailleau au tour de la
présidentielle 2022 et du mode de
désignation d'un candidat à droite et
xavier bertrand veut être candidat à la
présidentielle sans passer par une
primaire contrairement à valérie
pécresse laurent wauquiez et bruno
retailleau et sur ce point notez que le
patron du parti l'est républicain
christian jacob a renvoyé à la fin
septembre pour se mettre d'accord autour
d'un processus de désignation du
candidat de la droite et du centre à la
présidentielle
retour en salle les conférences avec une
nouvelle rédaction une nouvelle réaction
par dont celle du président de la
commission des lois
françois noël buffet qui est avec steve
jourdain ouï me suis fait bon jour dans
quelques minutes va débuter l'examen du
texte 3ds cadets enfin le texte sur la
décentralisation il assez ambitieux ce
texte selon vous
selon nous il est insuffisamment
ambitieux en réalité on s'attendait à un
moment à avoir la tête 4 3 ou 4 de la
bourse de la décentralisation
finalement tout ça ça n'est pas le cas
on est sur un texte de diverses mesures
concernant les collectivités locales qui
certes peuvent avoir un intérêt
d'ailleurs le sénat a fort des 50
propositions qu'il avait faite va
retranscrire dans ce texte ces
propositions la semaine il a été entendu
sur ces points ces différents points par
le gouvernement selon vous écoutez nous
sommes en première lecture nous allons
voir caso va dire le gouvernement aux
bandes en quelques minutes des dix ans
d'intervention de dans la discussion
générale
j'espère que nous serons entendus
j'espère que l'on tiendra compte de la
haute assemblée qui en charge des
collectivités locales qui a fait des
propositions depuis longtemps qui a
travaillé là-dessus qui je pense est
parfaitement pertinente dans le travail
alors c'est un texte très complexe il
faut le dire est ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer ce qui va changer très
concrètement pour ceux qui nous
regardent aujourd'hui très content 4
mélanger c'est raide c'est très
difficile pardon parce que il ya de
multiples mesures qui intéresse les
communes les départements voir les
régions on va discuter bien sûr de de
partage de compétences de capacité à
agir de façon autonome de la part des
intercommunalités ou des communes donc
c'est une succession de mesures qu'il
faut cas on donnera sans doute au
territoire on va essayer de terroir plus
de liberté plus d'autonomie pour pouvoir
agir au quotidien au mieux des intérêts
des des habitants des territoires
mais il n'y a pas une
philosophie unique où une ligne
directrice elles sont multiples la
grande mesure quand même du texte dans
le contexte sanitaire actuelle c'est
l'instauration d'une coprésidence préfet
président de région sur les ars agences
régionales de santé vous y est favorable
oui c'est plutôt une bonne chose que le
pouvoir d erez soient partagées avec les
pouvoirs des présidents de région dont
on a vu à l'occasion de la crise qu'ils
ont été très rapidement à la manoeuvre
est très utiles à l'organisation de
l'action de terrain donc je pense que
c'est une bonne chose ça renforce aussi
le lien entre l'état et les
collectivités locales dans la gestion
d'une pandémie tels que nous sommes en
train encore de la vivre un peu malgré
tout
merci beaucoup fonctionnel bien
s'élancer d'avoir répondu à mes
questions merci beaucoup steve est
effectivement dans quelques minutes vous
allez pouvoir suivre en direct sur
public sénat le début de l'examen au
sénat de ce projet loi de
décentralisation avant le début de la
séance ouverte rhône on va retourner en
tribune de presse de l'hémicycle du
sénat
quand un calme et à ce projet de loi de
décentralisation il est très attendu par
les sénateurs oui c'est vrai peut-être
que loyers sur les images qui est
effectivement diffuse
l'hémicycle mais jacqueline gros est
déjà installé sur le banc des ministres
elle est prête pour le début de la
discussion générale autour du projet de
loi de son projet de loi 4d alors 4d
qu'est ce que ça signifie
on parle de décentralisation de
différenciation de des concentrations
alors il ya vingt quatrième des qui
était le terme de des complexification
mais le conseil d'état a jugé que
c'était là un barbarisme il a préféré
des diverses mesures de simplification
d'où le fait que certains observateurs
parlent de projet de loi 3ds et qui est
donc maintenant un petit peu le nouveau
nom de ce texte on l'attendait
effectivement depuis de nombreux mois on
pensait kim finalement n'arriverait
jamais ici au parlement mais finalement
en janvier dernier n'a compris que ce
texte verrait bien le jour
ce texte porte vraiment sûr beaucoup de
petites mesures qui sont très concrètes
pour les collectivités locales d'où le
fait que ça intéresse beaucoup les
sénateurs mais qui sont ses vrais
difficile à comprendre pour le français
le citoyen lambda parce qu'on parle de
nouvelles compétences et
d'expérimentation dans les régions on
parle d' expérimenter la
recentralisation du du rsa qui pèse
lourd dans le budget des départements
mais ça beaucoup de sénateurs et les
sénateurs n'en veulent pas que ça va
faire et ça l'a fait l'objet d'âpres
négociations dans l'hémicycle on parle
aussi de la gouvernance des agences
régionales de santé qui doivent être
mieux réparti sa gouvernance doit être
mieux réparti avec les collectivités
locales et on avait vu en mai dernier
que dès la présentation de ce projet de
loi et des présidents de départements
avaient dénoncé et bien d un texte sans
relief et donc depuis le début de
l'examen de ce texte en commission les
sénateurs ont tenté de faire ajouter des
mesures que eux avaient travaillé avec
les collectivités locales vous savez
c'est un représentant des territoires va
vouloir comme ça amendé le texte c'est
parti pour cette séance qui commence
tout de suite
[Musique]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président un rappel au règlement qui se
fonde sur l'article 36 de celui ci vous
n'êtes pas censé savoir puisque la
présidente à ça si vous interpellez dès
la semaine dernière sur ce que je vais
qualifier une utilisation à nos yeux
abusive de l'article 40 ayant d'ailleurs
conduit avant l'examen en séance ce jour
du texte 3ds de plusieurs dizaines
oserais-je dire d'ailleurs presque
centaine puisqu'il y en a plus de 200
amendements de tous les groupes jugés
irrecevables au titre de l'article 40
pour une grande partie de ces
amendements qui ont été il recevable
il se souvient il visait à débattre du
rétablissement de la clause de
compétence générale de la capacité à
pouvoir déléguer des compétences d'une
collectivité à l'autre et à aucun moment
donné il était dit dans ces amendements
est elle d'ailleurs n'était pas
l'objectif d'augmenter quelques dépenses
que ce soit faut-il rappeler à la
commission des finances qu'aucun de ces
amendements bien évidemment ne visait à
remettre en cause la règle de
l'équilibré budgétaire des collectivités
territoriales faut-il rappeler à la
commission des finances que les choix au
sein des collectivités territoriales et
de leurs assemblées sont des choix
politiques et que dans un même budget
bien évidemment il peut y avoir des
choix différents
nous sommes également surpris pour notre
part sur un certain nombre d'amendements
puisque notre à mon nom numéro 2 181
avait été en son temps déposé et validé
par la commission des finances lors du
projet de loi de finances 2011 21
l'amendement 253 avait été validé et
débattues à l'occasion du projet de loi
est lent de même pour le numéro 2 147 et
enfin pour le 256 qui avaient été
débattus ici même en 202 2019 dans le
cadre de la loi engageant et proximité
monsieur
président alors que nous allons ouvrir
la discussion générale nous voudrions
avoir des explications concrètes avant
l'examen de ces amendements
en effet pourquoi une telle évolution y
at il eu une évolution de la
jurisprudence si oui par qui puisque la
commission des finances n'étant pas une
juridiction elle n'a pas matière à faire
évoluer quelques jurisprudences que ce
soit nous regrettons en tout cas à cette
heure de ne pas avoir reçu de réponse et
d'explications de la part du président
de la commission des finances monsieur
masson pour un rappel au règlement
oui monsieur le président depuis
quelques années maintenant nous avons
enfin le sénat a introduit une certaine
transparence sur l'utilisation des frais
de mandat et cette transparence s'exerce
sur sous l'autorité du comité
déontologie mais je pense qu'il serait
également opportun que le comité de
déontologie soit lui-même transparent et
que quand il l'a instaure une
jurisprudence ou deux
une nouvelle règle il en informe
l'ensemble des sénateurs
je vais vous donner un exemple qui
concerne en particulier les sénateur non
inscrit
nous avons dans la rubrique des dépenses
une dépense de la catégorie 9 qui
correspond au type dépenses initialement
j'avais moi même posé la question on
nous avait dit qu'on pouvait faire une
attestation pour l'ensemble de l'année
ce qui est beaucoup plus simple plus tôt
que la faire une par mois ou une tous
les deux mois ou une tous les trois mois
et donc on m'avait répondu par
l'affirmative
or il y a quelques jours j'ai reçu une
une réclamation en quelque sorte des
experts comptables me disant mais qu'est
ce qui se passe
pourquoi avez vous fait une seule
déclaration pour l'ensemble de l'année
alors on m'a moi j'ai indiqué qu'on
m'avait qu'on m'avait dit que c'était
comme ça qu'on pouvait très bien
procéder de la sorte et on m'a répondu
quelque chose que j'ai trouvé absolument
stupéfiant c'est que le comité
déontologie avait changé duris prudents
et que dorénavant il souhaitait que les
déclarations soient fractionné et que
l'information dessinateur avait été fait
de bouche à oreille les acéistes rats
ordinaire des informations fait de
bouche à oreille est nous qui sommes
sénateur non-inscrit bien entendu on est
au courant de rien alors moi je voudrais
quand même souhaité que quand il y à des
changement de jurisprudence et pourquoi
pas moi je suis tout à fait d'accord ce
qui est des changements le jurisprudence
mais que tous les sénateurs soient
informés correctement et le moyen
d'informer les sénateurs correctement
c'est les informer par écrit
parce que les sénateurs ne nasri ne
siège pas dans le comité de déontologie
ce sont donc les seuls qui ne sont pas
représentés dans le comité du rod au
logis enfin je réclame pas d'y siéger
rassurez vous monsieur le président mais
dans ces conditions là
logique de fonctionner de bouche à
oreille dans la mesure où nous n'avons
pas dit non nous ne sommes que deux et
que nous n'avons donc aucune source
d'information c'est tout à fait
impossible
alors je voudrais souhaiter monsieur le
président quel avenir et bien le comité
de déontologie informe par écrit quand
il ya des changements bête il informe
les élus par écrit ses vitres et quand
même beaucoup de contrariété bien je
vous donnerais tu vas te ce rappel au
règlement et je pense que le président
bazin le lire avec attention
je voudrais donner la parole sur le
rappel au règlement de même qu karman
qui souhaitaient qu avant que nous
entrions dans les débats nous ayons un
l'éclairage de la commission des
finances monsieur le président de la
commission des finances
oui merci et merci monsieur le président
ce en quelques mots d'abord pour
répondre à madame kuperman très
tranquillement je ne crois pas avoir
reçu de lettre
en tant que président de la commission
de finances il s'agit d'une lettre qui a
été adressée au président du sénat et
dont j'ai reçu copie
ce qui n'est pas exactement la même
chose qui me donne pas obligation de
réponse me semble-t-il autrement que ce
que je vais faire maintenant
le projet de loi relatif à la
différenciation la décentralisation la
déconcentration et portant diverses
mesures de simplification de l'action
publique locale 10 4 10 et un texte
essentiel pour nos collectivités
territoriales et donc pour le sénat qui
assure leur représentation
il a fait l'objet du dépôt de 1222
amendements au sein de la commission et
de 1690 amendements en vue de la séance
publique
environ 16 % c'est est supérieure à la
moyenne
mais c'est lire ce texte des amendements
dû être déclaré recevable au titre de
l'article 40 de la constitution
et en tant que sénateur combien cette
décision d'irrecevabilité limite le
débat parlementaire mais elle résulte
directement de la décision du conseil
constitutionnel du 14 décembre 2006 qui
impose je le cite un contrôle de
recevabilité effectifs y systématique au
moment du dépôt des amendements
si ce contrôle n'était pas effectif
d'ailleurs s'il n'était pas effective le
conseil constitutionnel soulèverait
lui-même lire ce domaine
l'irrecevabilité financière ceux qui
s'abstiennent de faire au nom de la
règle dite du préalable parlementaire
auquel nous tenons s'il le faisait comme
il le fait d'ailleurs au titre d
irrecevabilité duarte 45
il y aurait peu de chances que
l'initiative parlementaire y gagne
l'article 40 de la constitution empêche
en effet toute création d'une charge
publique qui s'entend au niveau de
chaque personne publique et ne permet
pas contrairement à ce qui est possible
en recettes de compenser la création
d'une charge par la diminution d'une
autre charge pour une autre personne
publique
aussi n'est-il pas possible mais vous le
savez de procéder par exemple des
transferts de compétences entre
catégories de collectivités locales ce
qui pourtant relève directement de
l'objet de ce texte
si par le passé certains amendements ont
pu être examinés par exemple dans les
lois nôtre est notable c'est dans la
plupart des cas parce qu'il revenait aux
droits existants et que la recevable la
recevabilité pardon prend comme base de
référence celle qui est la plus
favorable aux droits parlementaires
qu'il s'agisse du droit existant ou du
droit proposé aujourd'hui il en est
ainsi plus possible de revenir sur la
clause de compétence générale
c'est un site social aussi évoqué
évidemment par le gouvernement la
jurisprudence article 40 est stabilisée
depuis de nombreuses années j'en suis le
dépositaire près d'autres ses draps et
les quelques divergences qui ont pu
exister avec l'assemblée nationale ont
été aplanies d'ailleurs par mes
prédécesseurs grâce à des
assouplissements du jury ce we dance
je rappelle par ailleurs que le taux 10
ans habitait au sénat est constamment
inférieur à celui constaté à l'assemblée
nationale et que chaque fois que cela
était possible des rectifications sont
proposés aux auteurs des amendements
pour leur permettre de rendre leurs
amendements examinés
je suis très attentif par ailleurs il
arrive que des amendements passe
quelques fois l'article 40 dans d'autres
textes
c'est pas parce qu'ils ont passé
l'article 40 par erreur dans le passé
qu'il faut poursuivre dans l'erreur dans
le texte actuel c'est comme ça le débat
d'autres doit donc non pas se porter sur
l'article 40 par rapport à ce texte
mais de manière générale sur la
rédaction même de l'article 40 de la
constitution voire sur son existence
ce qui ne peut se faire qu'en réviser la
constitution je vous engage donc à
proposer à faire une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle sur